[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? On va
commencer par Taric.
Bah écoutez Tarik Rim, je suis
entrepreneur dans le web. J'ai
eu plusieurs carrières.
Euh j'ai démarré euh très tôt en
informatique, ça m'a c'était ma passion.
Et puis je suis parti après dans la
silicone vallée et je suis revenu en
France où j'ai monté plusieurs boîtes et
puis en ce moment je m'intéresse
essentiellement sur les question de
souveraineté numérique.
Bernard
Bernard donc je dirige actuellement donc
l'Institut de la souveraineté numérique
et après avoir été à de nombreuses
reprises du côté obscur de la force
c'estàdire dans différentes fonctions
auprès des gouvernements successifs et
toujours autour des questions
numériques, d'usage du numérique,
j'étais délégué interministériel et et
autour effectivement de tout ce qui
était régulation du numérique depuis en
gros une vingtaine d'années et où
effectivement j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer Taric à plusieurs reprises
sur ces questionsl Donc on merci. Donc
on on a décidé de vous faire venir ce
soir pour parler souveraineté numérique
euh pour parler privacy shield
euh pour parler tout un tas de choses
qui attraent notre souveraineté
numérique et d'autres sujets connexes.
Euh on va commencer par Taric.
Ah
Taric. Comment ça se passe en France ?
La souveraineté numérique c'est open
barés américaines, pour les sociétés
jordaniennes, israéliennes,
pour les sociétés saoudiennes. C'est
comment ? c'est est-ce qu'on a pour être
tout à fait trivial, est-ce qu'on a le
pantalon en dessous des genoux ?
Ah, vaste question.
Je pense que
on a on a un vrai problème en fait en
France, c'est qu'on a
on a l'impression qu'on est pas capable
de faire des choses, qu'on est pas
capable de construire ces
infrastructures. Ce qui est ce qui est
fascinant, c'est que depuis depuis 40
ans, en fait, j'ai même plus 50 ans, là,
je revoyais récemment un document
YouTube sur le le plan calcul et tu
avais Michel Debré qui parlait de la
souveraineté numérique. Tu changerais
pas une seule ligne.
Attends, je te coupe. Je vous demander à
la communauté. On a un problème de son
aujourd'hui.
Ah !
Alors, bougez pas. Son saccadé. On a un
son sacadé. Franchement, horrible. On va
retravailler le son. J'entends pas. Le
son n'est pas terrible. Donc
il y a un problème de son à gauche.
Tout est bon. Ça doit devenir de
YouTube.
C'est la caméra plan large. Tu me remets
caméra face. Je suis désolé de te couper
comme ça. Est-ce que en caméra face, on
a un son qui est correct ?
J'attends le retour de la communauté.
Faut faud qu'il parle aussi parce que si
personne parle
Ouais. Oui. N'hésitez pas de parler les
gars. Alors vous inquiétez pas, on a
encore on a encore du temps mais il faut
nous dire s'il y a du bon son sur
Discord.
Donc on continue. Je te recoupe. On va
croiser les doigts. Le son est OK
maintenant. On reste sur la plan face.
D'accord. Donc on revient sur
on revient sur la souveraineté numérique
et le fait qu'on essaie de courir avec
le pantalon en dessous des genoux.
Ça a pas toujours été le cas. Euh ce
qu'il faut comprendre, c'est que après
la 2e guerre mondiale, en gros, les
Américains ne veulent pas que l'Europe
dispose d'une industrie informatique
pour une simple raison, c'est que qui
dit ordinateur dit armes nucléaires,
donc dissuasion. Donc à ce moment-là, on
a vraiment un alignement parfait entre
la vision donc notamment celle du
général de Gaulle, la création de la
C2I, enfin toute toute une
infrastructure. Ce qui était assez
fascinant d'ailleurs à l'époque, c'est
qu'ils ont pas décidé de créer une
boîte, c'est de regrouper un ensemble de
boîtes autour d'un projet, donc
construire des calculateurs puisqueà
l'époque contrôle data qui faisit les
calculateurs un peu puissants, on avait
pas vraiment accès à à ce genre de
machine. Et on a eu cette vision qui est
assez euh française, c'est de dire on
fait nos trucs dans notre coin, on a
fait ça avec le TGI, on a fait ça avec
le Minitel, on construit nos réseaux,
nos infrastructures. Et ce qui est
fascinant, moi j'ai dans une ancienne
vie passé beaucoup de temps à bidouiller
les Minitel. Quand on ouvre un Minitel,
la première chose qui nous qui est
impressionnante, c'est tout est fabriqué
en France, absolument tout. Et les gens
le savent pas, mais le milit inspiré
Steve Jobs pour le Mcintosh puisque la
la poignée, le design et donc on est
parti de d'un d'un modèle où on faisait
tout à un modèle où on fait presque plus
grand-chose. Maintenant, on veut faire
le Data Hub, on est obligé de passer par
Microsoft, on veut faire telle chose,
les appels d'offre, on nous explique
qu'on ne sait plus faire. Et je pense
que c'est un c'est il y a plusieurs
raisons, mais la première c'est
l'expertise est là, mais les gens qui
ont l'expertise ne sont jamais les gens
qui décident. C'était pas le cas avant.
On avait beaucoup d'ingénieurs, de
polytechniciens, des gens un peu stricts
mais qui étaient des vrais ingénieurs
qui savaient construire, mettre en place
des équipes. Maintenant, on a plutôt des
J'appelle ça un peu des consultants,
c'est des gens qui font des PowerPoint
qui sont
technocrates.
Mais mais il y a eu des technocrates
éclairés. Là, on est vraiment dans le
dans le modèle où on a vu une
présentation de Google. C'est super et
c'est vrai que c'est très beau. C'est ça
qu'il faut faire. Alors qu'en fait quand
on construit des projets sur le long
terme, par exemple Lata mais tout ce
qu'on va faire, tout ce qui est nouveau
dans le numérique, on le fait pas pour 5
ans, on le fait pour 20 ans, 30 ans. Euh
quand on a fait le TGV, on n' pas dit
c'est un produit euh qu'on va faire pour
quelques années. Donc il y a une vision
long terme. Il faut donc la construire.
Et la construire c'est euh c'est
difficile. Il y a deux visions et la
vision Uber, on clique, la voiture
arrive en bas et puis on rentre dans la
voiture. Puis la vision, on passe son
permis de conduire, on achète sa
voiture, on apprend à la conduire. C'est
plus compliqué, c'est plus cher, mais
c'est ce qu'on doit faire.
Bernard, c'est pas un peu trop tard euh
de passer son permis de conduire, de
prendre sa voiture, d'apprendre à à
mettre la transition,
non ?
Dans une dans un climat de guerre
économique où tout s'accélère ? Euh on
pourrait penser et je pense que ce qui
ce qui est d'une certaine manière le
constat que font beaucoup aujourd'hui,
c'est que justement une fois la guerre
une fois que la guerre est perdue,
autant faire alliance avec les
vainqueurs. C'est une triste c'est une
triste résignation, une molle
résignation de certains y compris au
sein de l'État. Donc non, je crois que
euh non seulement il n'est pas trop
tard, mais je dirais que l'actualité des
technologies, c'est-à-dire l'actualité
des gars femme pour les appeler comme
ça, c'estàd les grandes sociétés
américaines du secteur montrent qu'on
est quasiment entré dans une crise,
alors certains disent crise systémique,
peu importe le terme, une crise de
confiance à l'échelle mondiale. C'estàd
que Facebook maintenant est en
trajectoire de collision avec un nombre
infini d'acteurs aussi bien public que
privés. Euh et c'est aussi quelque part
le cas de Google avec YouTube qui lui
aussi est un accélérateur de de
radicalisation. Et donc par définition,
je crois que ce modèle-là n'est pas
durable. De ça de ça, on est convaincu.
Mieux encore puisque j'entendais le mot
Privacy Shield qui a été prononcé en
tout début d'émission. Euh c'est un
plaisir de venir le lendemain de
l'annulation d'un traité transatlantique
qui effectivement était était je dirais
l'ombrelle pour 1500 ou 2000 sociétés
américaines pour essayer effectivement
de traiter les données des Européens aux
États-Unis. Moi, je fais partie de ceux
qui pensent qu'à terme puisque Tarik
cita le le le Dataup, donc le le nouveau
système de rassemblement des données de
santé des Français en un seul lieu euh à
déf de développer des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle, moi je je
pense que ces données ne peuvent pas,
quoi qu'il en soit sortir du territoire
européen, peut-être pas du territoire
français mais au moins européen. À
l'heure qu'il est, le fait que Microsoft
puisse traiter une partie de ces données
directement aux États-Unis pose un
problème. Et on vient de voir avec
l'annulation du Privacy Shield que la
justice européenne considère que les
données des Européens ne sont plus
sécurisé correctement par rapport aux
intrusions des systèmes des services de
renseignement par rapport effectivement
à l'usage que peuvent en faire des
sociétés et donc maintenant il une sorte
de tenaille qui est en train de
s'établir et ce qui était quasiment
inenvisageable il y a 5 ans quand
justement le prédécesseur du PRID qui
s'appelait à l'époque pour les pour les
plus fus qui s'appelait le Safe Harbor a
été annulé personne ne pensait que le
suivant serait annulé. Maintenant, tout
le monde est conscient que c'était
quasiment inéluctable et surtout on se
rend compte à quel point je veux dire on
ne peut plus reproduire la chose et
faire comme si de rien n'était et
continuer effectivement comme si
j'allais dire il n'y avait pas eu de
scandale Snowden, il y avait pas eu
d'affaires Cambridge Analytica, il y
avait pas eu effectivement toute une
série d'éléments qui montrent que les
Européens doivent sortir de l'innocence.
Je dirais la naïveté des Européens par
rapport aux Américains qui leur faisait
dire mieux vaut effectivement leur
confier leurs données nos données de
toute manière sont de belles et grandes
sociétés.
Aujourd'hui, on se rend compte que
Facebook non seulement est un acteur
économiquement toxique pour son
écosystème, on pourrait dire la même
chose de Google, mais que ce sont des
acteurs politiquement toxiques et qui
sont qui ont montré à plusieurs
reprises, je citerai des gens qui sont
pas des des anarcos libertaires
extrêmes, je citerai le le rapport du
Parlement britannique qui parle de
Facebook en disant "Ce sont des
gangsters numériques qui subvertissent
la démocratie."
Et donc voyez, typiquement ce propos là
intervient 9 ans après une certaine
Hillary Clinton qui disait par la voix
de son conseiller Alex Cross à l'époque
le numérique l'internet est devenu le
Tegevara du 21e siècle en pensant que à
l'époque c'était l'époque des printemps
arabes en pensant que que c'était
l'outil de libération des peuples.
Aujourd'hui, on se rend compte que que
l'internet peut être tout, y compris un
outil d'asservissement, y compris un
outil de contrôle. Nos amis chinois le
montrent tous les jours avec le crédit
social, ce système horswélien de
contrôle. Et donc nous européens qui
étions entre guillemets les mauvais
élèves du monde numérique dans le sens
où n'avions pas notre industrie propre
avec le règlement européen sur les
données, avec cette volonté que l'on a
justement de protéger une notion presque
dépassée sur année qu'on appelle la vie
privée, et ben quelque part on avait
raison. Et donc je pense que le rebond
européen pourrait prendre appui sur en
gros notre singularité par rapport aux
acteurs chinois évidemment et
effectivement aussi aux acteurs
américains.
Taric, ça pose quel type de problème
plus en détail le fait que nos datas
soient stocké aux États-Unis ou soient
renvoyé aux États-Unis ou peuvent être
exploités depuis les États-Unis depuis
une loi extraeuropéenne ? Si par exemple
les services secrets tombent sur nos
data, qu'est-ce qu'ils peuvent faire ?
que déjà ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que l'internet depuis
au moins 2002 enfin c'est la date que
qu'on se donne de temps en temps entre
est un espace militarisé. C'est-à-dire
que on prend un ordinateur, on le sort
d'une boîte, on le connecte. À l'époque,
je crois qu'il fallait 2 minutes pour
qu'il se qu'il soit transformé en
zombie. Maintenant ça prendrait même pas
30 secondes je pense peut-être même
moins. Je plus vraiment pas explique
faut t'expliquêtre
connecté, il y a des bots des des
services qui cherchent en permanence des
machines à hacker automatiquement
puisque comme elles sont pas mises à
jour, elles sortent de la boîte, elles
sont les les patchs de sécurité n'ont
pas été mis et on va les utiliser
ensuite pour plein d'actions
coordonnées.
Donc en fait l'espace d'internet est à
la fois un espace un théâtre militaire
de mais également un espace commercial
qu'il faut sécuriser. Donc ça pose un un
vrai problème parce que finalement ce
sont les mêmes tuyaux qui qu'Amazon
utilise pour nous vendre des chaussures
et que la NSA, la CIA, Cyber Commun et
les services évidemment de tous les
autres pays utilisent. Donc c'est
exactement le même réseau. Donc on a on
a ce problème c'est qu'on a pas su à
moment donné définir d'un point de vue
politique et ça Bernard l'a l'a suivi
des règles d'usage parce que le le en
gros la dans les dans les guerres de
type cyber à la différence du nucléaire
c'est c'est le premier qui a tiré qui a
perdu les guer cyber c'est l'inverse.
C'est le premier qui a tiré qui a gagné.
On a complètement et je sais que dans
les vieux magazines Worn qui un magazine
californien que tout le monde connaît,
il y a un auteur de science-fiction qui
est un peu l'un des parrains du
mouvement Cyberpunk qui expliquait quels
sont les 10 10 services qu'il faut alors
ça c'était en 93 qu'il faudrait faire
tomber pour faire tomber les États-Unis.
Et à l'époque l'internet était numéro 4
parce qu'il y avait encore des grides
privés. Aujourd'hui, évidemment, ce
serait la première des choses. On l'a vu
hier sur Twitter, finalement, on peut
hacker le compte Twitter de quelqu'un de
très connu et le plus connu d'entre eux,
si c'était Donald Trump, on pourrait
presque déclarer une guerre
une guerre nucléaire. Donc le problème
qu'on a au niveau des pour revenir sur
la question des des services de
renseignement, c'est que de toute façon
la l'écoute existe depuis depuis
toujours. Ce qui se fais ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui avec Google avec les les
gars femmes, ce que Snowden a a dévoilé
existait déjà avant dans les dans les
années 50 60 avec il y avait d'autres
projets s'appelait projet Minar qui a
donné ensuite échelon et puis ensuite on
a eu plein de plein de sujets. Mais ce
qui est nouveau aujourd'hui, c'est que
ces centres de données
analysent non plus les données
personnelles parce que ce qu'on ce qu'on
oublie, c'est que des sociétés comme
Facebook, Google ne travaillent plus
uniquement sur les données mais sur le
comportement. En gros, il y a il y a 10
ans, je veux savoir qui tu es pour te
vendre quelque chose. Aujourd'hui, je
vais utiliser ton comportement, le
nombre de fois que tu vas sur Instagram.
Si tu t'arrêtes quelques millisecondes
sur une photo, ah tiens, tu as envie de
voyager, est-ce que tu es déprimé ?
Est-ce que tu es euphorique pour
transformer ton comportement ? Ce qui
s'est passé, c'est que la plupart des
acteurs de la vallée ont se sont
rencontrés. Alors, c'est Nathan Mirvolt
qui était le le chief scientiste de de
Microsoft qui a présenté sur c'est Dian
Can qui avait fait la Think Fast and
Slow, le marketing comportemental et en
fait la les équipes, il y avait les gens
de Google, il y avait les gens d'Amazon,
il y avait les gens de Facebook. La
personne de de Facebook qui a compris
parfaitement ce que devait comment
utiliser ces techniques, c'était Shan
Parker qui à l'époque était le président
de Facebook. Et donc ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que Facebook n'était pas
très intéressé intéressé à ça jusqu'à ce
que Sheril Sandberg vienne de Google
avec finalement la vision du capitalisme
de surveillance, c'estàdire monétiser
les données à outrance et avec cette
idée qu'on peut modifier les
comportements pour vendre. Et le et le
problème que l'on a aujourd'hui, c'est
que quand on modifie le comportement
d'un consommateur, c'estàd qu'on veut le
rendre dépressif parce que quand il est
dépressif, il va plutôt acheter des
voyages. Quand il est euphorique, il va
s'acheter des chaussures. Enfin bon, je
je schématise, mais quand on touche au
psych
euh parce que d'une certaine manière ce
qui ce qui ce qui est fascinant, c'est
quand on rêve le soir, on notre
subconscient en fait est alimenté par
toutes les images qu'on a vu dans la
rue, dans à la télévision. Aujourd'hui,
une grande partie, voir la majorité des
images qui sont en fait euh euh perçues
par notre cerveau viennent des écrans.
Ce sont des images qui ont été choisi.
Ce que l'on voit sur Instagram a été
choisi. Si on vous déprimez, ben on va
vous montrer la photo de votre ancienne
petite amie au lever et immédiatement on
va changer votre caractère. Alors vous
allez vous dire "Non, c'est mais ça ça
marche ça marche très bien. J'avais
rencontré un garçon Itamar là chez
Facebook qui sont ils avaient fait des
tests, ils ont arrêté mais et lui
d'ailleurs a quitté depuis Facebook
déprimé. On est capable de modifier les
comportements et on modifie les
comportements pour le commerce. Mais
quand on modifie le comportement pour le
commerce, on modifie aussi la partie
citoyenne d'une personne et donc
pour les élections. Et ce qui est
fascinant, c'est qu'on est dans un monde
aujourd'hui qui est qui est compliqué
parce qu'on a une hyper fragmentation
algorithmique. C'estd qu'on a construit
euh donc avant on avait la télévision,
on avait on avait 15 20 niches,
maintenant on est rentré dans des micro
niches qui targetent parfois quelques
personnes. Là il y a un groupe
terroriste un peu d'extrême droit enf
terroristes parce qu'ils ont tué des
gens en Californie qui s'appelle
Buggelou. Boglou et je crois que tous
les membres se sont rencontrés grâce à
Facebook. Donc on a on a construit une
espèce de de fragmentation algorithmique
permanente. On crée des microniches. Moi
ce que je pense c'est que les
microniches ça crée de la médiocrité
parce qu'on est on est un peu le borgne
au milieu d'un microonde d'aveugle et en
fait on ne on ne communique plus.
effectivement euh ça a construit alors
dans le avec YouTube euh mais aussi avec
Facebook ce que j'appelle souvent la
radicalisation algorithmique,
c'est-à-dire qu'on on on travaille une
personne euh mentalement et ces
techniques qui sont des techniques de
comportement de modification
comportementale sont les techniques qui
ont été inventées dans les années 60 par
la CIA par tous les services de
renseignement pour modifier le psicher.
Elles ont été en fait boostées par le
fait que désormais avec le téléphone on
est seul.
On va aller voter, on va voter pour
Hillary et puis on va aux toilettes et
puis on pense son téléphone et là on
voit un truc, une fake news sur Hillary.
On est là, on est énervé, on est
vraiment énervé, c'est le bon moment et
puis on change son vote à la la dernière
minute. Ce qui a changé en fait entre
l'élection de Trump et l'élection
d'Obama, c'est que l'élection d'Obama,
c'est une élection internet alors que
l'élection de Trump, c'est devenu une
élection sur le smartphone et le
smartphone en fait est un appareil
unique. Moi, personne ne regarde votre
téléphone. Personne ne regarde ton
téléphone. Bernard, c'est quelque chose
de privé. Donc, on a cette capacité et
elle a été utilisée. Les services de
renseignement, à mon avis euh n'osent
pas faire ce genre de choses parce que
ils le font peut-être il ils ont pas les
les je pense aujourd'hui honnêtement que
Facebook, Google et toutes ces
plateformes ont moins de scrupules à
utiliser ces techniques parce que c'est
du commerce que les serv les services de
renseignement.
Il y a pas porosité entre les services
de renseignement et les gafins ?
Bien sûr que si
Bernard,
bien sûr que si. S'il y a bien une chose
qu'a démontré l'affaire Cambridge
Analytica, hein, pour ceux euh qui n'en
auraient pas entendu parler, donc cette
cette énorme affaire effectivement
durant le la préparation donc de
l'élection américaine, c'est que d'une
part les données peuvent être traitées
par des psychologues spécialistes des
euh
ah des opération opération psychologique
psyops
psyops. Donc typiquement, on voit bien
que il y avait il y avait plusieurs
plusieurs convergences, je dirais et que
ce que décrit très bien d'ailleurs, je
la conseille à tous vos auditeurs et et
spectateurs, Choshanazubov dans son
bouquin sur le capitalisme de
surveillance qui malheureusement n'est
pas traduit en français. Voyez, c'est il
traduit en allemand mais pas encore en
français. J'espère qu'il y aura un
éditeur très bientôt. Je crois que c'est
le cas. Euh typiquement, on voit bien
qu'il y a une convergence entre
l'activité économique qui se nourrit de
la data et l'activité des services de
renseignement qui c'est une tendance de
ces dernières décennies a de plus en
plus été vers le signal
technologique plutôt que le signal
humain. Donc utilise de plus en plus la
data et donc comme le rappelait
justement on en est plus au stade
d'analyser, on est au stade de
manipuler. Et donc pour ceux qui sont en
mesure d'agir, Tar faisait référence au
fait de pouvoir changer l'état d'esprit,
l'humeur d'une personne, on sait très
bien que pour aller vers un vote
extrême, on on aura plus intérêt à faire
que la personne soit en colère. Une
personne qui est sereine, qui est zene,
a priori aura moins tendance à aller
vers extrême. En tout cas, c'est comme
ça que la chose a été a été articulée.
Donc oui, typiquement, on sait
maintenant que modifier la la le news
feed sur Facebook permet de modifier
l'état d'humeur des gens. On sait qu'en
leur montrant ce qu'a bien démontré une
autre spécialiste Zenb Toufeki, une
turco-américaine remarquable sociologue
sur la radicalisation via les vidéos
justement en particulier sur YouTube, on
sait effectivement que si on montre des
choses de plus en plus hard, ce qu'elle
dit très bien, elle dit "Rien n'est
jamais trop hard pour YouTube." Voilà ce
qu'elle dit. Et elle concluait un de ses
articles en disant Et elle concluait un
de ces articles en disant euh
YouTube est peut-être devenu le
principal outil de de radicalisation du
21e siècle parce que justement la
puissance du choix algorithmique en
fonction des personnes en allant vers
des vidéos de plus en plus hard en
montrant des messages de plus en plus
radicaux tout à l'heure Tar évoquer les
les micronies c'estàd les les les bulles
informationnelles comme on les appelle.
La particularité aujourd'hui, c'est que
on fait en sorte que des gens ne
rentrent jamais en contact avec des
idées qui les dérangent. Pas simplement
des idées différentes, non, mais des
idées qui remettent en cause leur schéma
de vie. Et donc, on crée des groupes qui
ne se parlent jamais entre eux. c'est
qui ont
bah ceux qui ont intérêt à le faire,
c'est-à-dire ceux qui tant d'un point de
vue économique que d'un point de vue
politique ont envie de faire en sorte
qu'une partie de la population devienne
captive par rapport à un certain type de
comportement
ou d'idéologie
ou d'idéologie. Sachant que la
consommation, ça a très bien été étudié
par des publicitaires depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années, y compris nos actes
de consommation quotidien. La soupe
Cambell, vous savez, qu'on qu'on voyait
dans le le tableau de Warre était
apparemment plutôt une soupe consommée
par les républicains. Ne me demandez pas
pourquoi, j'en sais strictement rien.
Mais de fait, de même pour les voitures,
je crois que certaines marques étaient
plus entre guillemets progressistes,
démocrates que d'autres qui étaient plus
républicaines, chevrelé versus fortes,
je crois. Mais typiquement, on sait
qu'on est capable d'agir sur le
comportement des gens en fonction de
toutes sortes d'informations qui nous
viennent et qu'après évidemment ceux qui
ont intérêt pour des raisons politiques,
que ce soit des puissances étrangères,
que ce soit effectivement des partis
politiques parfois même en collusion
l'un avec l'autre puisque c'était un
petit peu de ça dont il était question
euh
sur la Russie
sur la Russie en particulier. Euh,
typiquement, ben l'affaire Stone qui
vient juste de rebondir récemment était
liée à des contacts répétés avec des
officiels russes, des officiers du
renseignement russe. Donc typiquement,
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on a les
instruments
avec des moyens limités, avec des
groupes de personnes limitées. La
célèbre agence russe Internet Research
Agency sont des moyens qui sont pas
énormes mais qui permettent d'influencer
comme on l'a vu pour Cambridge Analy,
agence russe privée.
Oui.
Donc c'est c'est un privé. Alors là
qui a des porosités avec le
gouvernement,
il semblerait. Je je ne suis pas je ne
suis pas un un russologue aussi aussi
distingué que certains de vos invités,
mais de fait oui, on pense effectivement
qu'il y a eu une une interaction de l'un
par rapport à l'autre et donc
typiquement voyez par exemple
qu's ont laissé faire.
Oui. Et et et et ce qui était amusant
c'est de voir le processus c'est c'était
pas voter Trump, c'était vous ne serez
pas correctement représenté par Hillary
Clinton. À quoi bon allez voter ? Et
donc c'était éteindre le vote démocrate
en particulier pour les Afro-Américains.
Donc vous voyez, typiquement, on on
maîtrise de mieux en mieux ces
phénomèneslà. Et ce qui est le plus
inquiétant pour revenir aux questions de
souveraineté numérique, c'est que pour
l'instant les États ne sont pas en
mesure de faire valoir la défense de
certains principes, y compris à des
sociétés comme Facebook.
Tarik, on fait comment pour éviter
l'astrurfing
de nos élections ? Est-ce qu'on fait la
la Est-ce qu'on fait du brois médiatique
comme les les 10 dernières années, du
moins les 5 dernières années avec un
gouvernement qui
qui, excusez-moi d'être très trivial,
mais qui fait sa pleureuse en disant "Oh
là là, les Russes, ils font des bêtises,
ils font des bêtises." C'est pas bien.
C'est pas bien les Russes, c'est les
méchants les Russes. Où est-ce qu'on
muscle un peu le cerveau de de nos
concitoyens ? Est-ce qu'on se donne des
outils pour les repérer plus facilement
? Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Ben, a il y a
plusieurs plusieurs sujets. Le premier,
c'est qu'on
Comment on fait pour réinvestir
la dialectique et comment on fait pour
éviter que la population soit laissée
aux quatre vents de toutes les
propagandes ? Alors, il y a un vrai il y
a un vrai il y a un vrai sujet
là-dessus, c'est déjà on a très rarement
appris la rhtorique. Aujourd'hui, celui
qui parle le mieux, on l'a vu avec les
débats. Alors, après, queles que soient
les opinions des uns et les autres,
hydroxychloroquis et cetera, on a on a
vu que le Covid, on est sur un sujet
scientifique euh voir et et souvent et
médical, la plupart des gens qui
aimeraient en parler, qui aimeraient
être présents sur les plateaux de télé,
celui j'y comprends rien. Il en a même
vu on en parlait des des journalistes
qui savaient pas ce qui était une courbe
exponentielle. Donc on est on était
vraiment à un niveau zéro en science.
Mais la rhtorique
vraiment la rhtorique la rhtorique est
importante et de comprendre que quand
quelqu'un et c'est là où c'est très
intéressant quand on voit les 10 scènes
par exemple de la Cour suprême, vous
avez des gens qui disent qui défendent
des points de vue opposés à leur vue
mais de manière tellement brillante que
vous êtes prêt à leur dire ah il a
raison et de dire l'inverse. Donc il
faudrait qu'on apprenne un peu euh on a
le concours d'éloquence. Voilà,
peut-être que donc ça c'est la première
chose. La deuxième c'est qu'on a un
cancer le on est passé si vous voulez
dans les années 90 de ce qu'on appelait
online communities, milliers de
personnes, on a connu les débuts le
well, toutes ces communautés aux réseaux
médias sociaux pardon, les blogs, des
millions d'utilisateurs à des
plateformes, on est désormais des
milliards d'utilisateurs. et et ce dont
on ne parle pas de ce dont tu parlais
tout à l'heure euh Bernard avec YouTube,
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est dans un
monde de fast food. Pour moi, Google
Facebook, c'est le McDonald's de la
pensée. Ce qui est fascinant avec
McDonald's, c'est que le le le Big Mac,
c'est la même recette dans tous les pays
quasiment. Par contre, en France, on
prend de la viande française, de la
salade française, des pommes de terre
françaises. Donc, on a construit un
algorithme qui est finalement le même.
Alors, j'aime pas dire un algorithme
parce que je déteste les gens qui
parlent des algorithmes, mais on a on a
créé un ensemble d'éléments de
programmes qui nous permettent
d'identifier, d'analyser une personne.
C'est les mêmes que ce soit simplement
les le substrat, donc les matières sur
lesquelles on va construire un profil
sont différentes. Donc on a créé en
fait, on est tous énervés pour les mêmes
raisons, on est tous euphoriques pour
les mêmes raisons. Donc on a créé en
fait un système de massification de la
personnalisation. On n pas en fait de
système personnel. La deuxième chose
c'est que le cancer des de nos de nos
dernières années, c'est le ce qu'on
appelle le behavior microargeting. Donc
le microiblage
comportemental.
On vous cible en fonction de vos
comportements, de vos habitudes, de ce
qu'on a compris de vous. pas parce que
vous vous intéressez à des céréales ou
acheter une Toyota. Et le drame pour
moi, ce qui est finalement le la chose
qui me qui m'énerve le plus dans ces 20
dernières années parce que
malheureusement ou heureusement, je
connais un peu les gens qui fabriquent
ces choses chez Google, chez Facebook,
les plus grands génies en mathématiques
ont soit servi à détruire le système
financier avec les dérivés et les les
marchés dérivés, les subprime. Et
aujourd'hui, la génération d'après, qui
normalement devrai réfléchir à à
d'autres sujets en fait passent leur
journée à optimiser les algorithme pour
vendre mieux des Toyota sur sur
Facebook. Là, on a en fait un un
savoir-faire incroyable qui a été mis
dans quelque chose qu'on pensait
inviolable puisque ce qui est assez
incroyable dans l'histoire de Facebook,
c'est que un ils l'ont su assez tôt Alex
Tamos qui était l'ancien patron de la
sécurité a dit très rapidement
on a un problème on a étouffé l'affaire
mais surtout ce qui s'est passé c'est
que ils se sont fait avoir. C'est que
d'une certaine d'un certain côté vous
avez Facebook qui dit "On est capable à
son annonceur annonceur, on est capable
de savoir exactement qui peut faire
quoi, comment, combien de gens ont vu le
clic." Et dès qu'on parle des des
problématiques liées à la campagne là,
"Ah ah non, je crois qu'on a pas
vraiment toutes les données." Donc ils
ont un un un ils se sont ils se sont
fait avoir par des gens qui étaient bien
plus malins queeux. Et puis surtout, on
l'oublie de le dire dans la campagne de
Trump. Ce qui est génial, c'est que la
campagne d'Hilary avait ses spécialistes
en big data et cetera. Donc, ils avaient
fait leur leur sauce. l'équipe de Trump
qui avait pas autant d'argent, Brad
Pascal d'ailleurs qui vient d'être
apparemment si j'ai compris viré par
Trump
a dit aux gens de Facebook parce qu'il
avaient ils avaient ce qu'ils appelaient
le projet à la moto. Donc ils avaient
des il y avait Cambridge Anatica, il y
avait plein de gens mais il y avait des
gens de Facebook qui étaient prêtés
entre guillemets par Facebook mais
comment on peut faire pour micrargetter
et donc ils l'ont fait de manière
extrêmement efficace puisque comme le
disait Bernard on a surtout travaillé à
à faire du vote de la suppression de de
vote. Cette technique à mon avis devrait
être interdite en Europe, complètement
interdite.
On a les bénéfices, c'estàdire vendre
plus de Toyota ou vendre des céréales
des Renault ou des scéniques.
Voilà. Ou des scéniques et des Renault
ou d'autres produits. Paron. C'est vrai
que j'utilise toujours vendre des
produits de consommation ne mérite pas
de menacer la démocratie parce que
soudain, moi j'ai jamais de problème
avec les gens que les gens pensent ce
qu'ils veulent mais là on sent que les
gens sont manipulés par des méthodes
grossières parce qu'encore une fois
pour toi
non mais je je m'explique quand on
l'algorithme de YouTube ça c'est c'est
pas moi qui dit c'était Yan Lecoun qui
est notre grande pointure en I et qui a
un peu vendu Il faut dire son âme chez
chez Facebook. Il le dit, il dit quand
Facebook vous arrivez pour la première
fois pardon sur YouTube, il faut que au
bout de 5 vidéos, on soit capable de
vous proposer une 6e vidéo qui soit à
peu près à peu près que vous avez pas
envie vous avez envie de voir. Donc en
fait, on fait un travail assez grossier
et ce travail assez grossier, c'est
cette base, ce substrat sur lequel on va
travailler ensuite. Et donc
fondamentalement, on n' jamais travaillé
sur un approfondissement. Donc tous les
algorithmes de de ciblage, de
microciiblage sont assez grossiers. Euh
c'est on doit faire de l'argent très
vite et ça pose un problème parce qu'il
y a aucune régulation. On est c'est
difficile hein de de réguler ce que vous
ne voyez pas. Le régulateur en
Angleterre, il y a des publicités sur le
Brexit, ils ne les ont jamais vu. Ils
savent même pas qu'elles existent. Elles
ont elles ont été vues 3 mois après le
vote. Donc on a on a un vrai un vrai
sujet. Pour moi la je dirais que la la
alors je sais que ça plaît pas beaucoup
aux gens de de la tech quand je dis ça,
mais il faut supprimer arrêter le le
micro targeting. C'està-dire qu'il faut
revenir à la publicité classique où on
fait du du ciblage plus classique, un
peu plus grossier mais qui n'est pas
après utilisé comme un outil de de
Alors, je te donne la parole tout de
suite. Je repose une question à Tarique.
Est-ce qu'on peut intoxiquer à l'échelle
du particulier l'algorithme
quand par intoxiqué ? Juste pour bien
être d'avoir compris la question.
Intoxiqué, c'est-à-dire si je je sais
que tu es très fan des des vidéos de
youtubeuse beauté. Donc si tu regardes
tes cinq premières vidéos de youtubeuse
beauté, est-ce que l'algo YouTube, je
sais que tu aimes pas dire l'algo, va
penser que tu es fan de youtubeuse
beauté ?
Est-ce que tu as compris le principe ?
Moi je me alors
d'accord, je te le fais en plus simple.
Oui.
Tu vas sur Youorn,
d'accord ?
Tu regardes que des vidéos où il y a des
blacks. Ouais.
On va te proposer que des vidéos avec
des blacks.
Oui.
Alors, est-ce qu'il y a moyen de
l'intoxiquer ?
De modifier le renforcement de
l'algorithme de façon de façon fausse de
manière à l'induire l'induire en erreur.
Exactement. Bernard.
Alors
oui oui, bien sûr bien sûr. Mais bien
sûr. Non, je t'en prie. Non non mais en
fait il y a deux forces en ce moment
chez il y a deux types d'algorithmes
chez chez chez Facebook. Il y a les
algorithmees qui veulent intoxiquer les
gens et donc qui veulent nous montrer
tous les contenus y compris ceux qui
rapportent le plus d'argent puisque
finalement
c'est très neutre. C'est la bottom line
c'est vraiment
c'est triste à dire mais mais Facebook
est passé d'une boîte qui était très
technologique et une boîte qui est
vraiment focalisée sur la monétisation.
Euh et à côté de ça, il y a les
algorithmes dites de
monitoring parce que comme ils se sont
fait taper sur les doigts avec les
Roinga, avec la la campagne, donc ils
ont créé des outils pour faire un peu la
police. Et donc on a ces deux
algorithmes qui se qui se battent en
duel, mais évidemment celui qui est là
pour rapporter de l'argent marche plus.
Alors, est-ce que une personne seule
peut modifier les les l'algorithme qu'il
lui est qui lui est imposé ? Je ne crois
pas. Je pense même que beaucoup de
d'outils alors je sais pas si vous
rappelez à l'époque d'échelon, il y
avait eu une histoire où l'échelon donc
c système de la NSA basé sur les mots
clés. Quelqu'un avait récupéré des mot
une liste de mots clés, avait dit "On va
mettre nos mots clés dans tous les
emails et on va on va on va entre
saturer le réseau le réseau estelon."
La la réalité c'est qu'en fait les gens
utilisaient un seul mot clé et donc dès
qu'il y avait dès qu'il y avait un
ensemble de mots clés, évidemment le le
mail était ignoré et donc ça servait à
rien. Euh ce qui est ce qui est ce qui
est très intéressant dans ces ces
plateformes, c'est que les algorithmes
changent énormément euh avec toujours la
même question, c'est comment
l'engagement est le plus fort. Donc si
quelque chose ne marche plus, c'est
comme un vieux disque, on change de
disque, on passe à autre chose. Et
souvent, on va vers des choses, comme le
disait Bernard, qui sont de plus en plus
euh euh ennuyeuses parce qu'on pousse
les gens vraiment au limite euh de leur
de leur psychologie.
Absolument.
Bernard.
Oui. Non non, je pense que le problème
c'est que euh là où auparavant on
réfléchissait en terme de navigation sur
internet, c'est-à-dire en gros est-ce
que on peut justement modifier son sur S
surf de manière à induire entre
guillemets en erreur l'algorithme ? Le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
données que peuvent rassembler les data
brokers donc ces gigantesques
agrégateurs de données viennent de
sources infini. Et donc le problème
c'est que par exemple on a découvert
lors de l'affaire Cambridge Analytica
que Facebook accumulait des données de
santé en masse y compris sur des gens
qui n'étaient pas abonnés Facebook
simplement par le biais effectivement
des de par le truchement des relations
qu'elles avaient avec des personnes qui
étaient sur Facebook et par le par les
informations qu'on pouvait collecter
d'elles au travers de leur navigation
sur des pages où il y avait des des
scripts Facebook. Donc par définition,
on se rend compte aujourd'hui que
le le enfin la possibilité de ne pas
alimenter le le les profils qui qui
parfois chez ces data brokers
contiennent des milliers de paramètres
différents sur une personne. Le
journaliste du Financial Times qui a
fait une grande enquête sur eux qui
portait une une un titre marrant qui
disait "Ce sont devenus les les les
étoiles de la mort de la vie privée en
reprenant la métaphore de Star Wars."
Ben, typiquement, le journaliste a
découvert dans dans son profil de l'un
de ces je crois que c'était Expérien ou
Axium, on va voir. Dans l'un de ses
profils, il a découvert qu'il était à
risque pour des maladies du rein, chose
qu'il ne savait pas et qu'il a vu
confirmer par la suite par son médecin.
Donc vous voyez, typiquement, je pense
que le le fait de se cacher, c'était le
titre du bouquin de Grenval justement
sur sur Snowden, nulle part où se
cacher. Je pense qu'aujourd'hui, vu
l'ampleur de ces sociétés et vu les
liens qu'elles ont les unes avec les
autres, c'est quasiment impossible. Je
crois que pour aller au-delà parce que
je je j'adhère totalement à l'idée que
le microargeting est toxique d'un point
de vue politique et d'un point de vue
sociologique, il est toxique mais je
crois qu'il faut aller plus loin.
C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui, c'est ce
que réclamait d'ailleurs Ellisabeth
Waren, la candidate démocrate à la
primaire, je crois qu'il nous faut
sérieusement envisager le démantlement
de ces sociétés et je précise que les
rachats récents de WhatsApp, d'Instagram
ont été faits, je dirais, en mentant à
la Commission européenne. Les les les
économistes Valetti en particulier
avaient l'occasion de s'exprimer en
disant en gros, on s'est fait avoir.
Donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui ces rachats
successifs doivent être véritablement
analysés. Est-ce que l'Europe peut à
elle seule empêcher des fusions ? Oui,
ça s'est vu dans le passé. Ça s'est vu
dans le passé en particulier dans les
turbines d'avion. Il y a eu des deals
avec Owel qui ont pas pu se faire à la
demande de l'Europe entre deux sociétés
américaines et au début des années 2000.
Donc typiquement aujourd'hui empêcher
Facebook de racheter sa prochaine proie
euh pour encore plus consolider son
pouvoir, ce n'est pas de la
science-fiction, c'est une possibilité.
Aujourd'hui, on en parlait, le fait de
ne plus pouvoir transférer les données
aux États-Unis fortune hier parlait d'un
possible chaos pour le commerce
électronique. Alors, je sais pas s'il
faut aller aussi loin mais mais de fait
on voit bien que on est dans une période
où les risques par rapport à ces
sociétés peuvent venir de l'Europe.
Est-ce que est-ce que on doit continuer
à faire comme si de rien n'était, comme
malheureusement ça a été trop le cas
dans les dernières années ? Non. Est-ce
que est-ce qu' est-ce qu'on a des
instruments ? Oui, mais et ça je je
pense que c'est c'est un des points sur
lesquels on doit absolument renouveler
la doctrine, c'est que on n' pas dans la
période récente eu une doctrine de
politique industrielle européenne ou
française à la hauteur des enjeux. Et
donc quelque part, on s'est on s'est
confié. Alors Tar a eu l'occasion de
parler de la France qui s'est vendue au
GF femme lors de ces 10 ou 15 dernières
années.
C'est vendu ou prostitué. Ça je me je je
je modifierai pas le terme mais de fait
de fait je dirais qu'il y a eu une sorte
de complaisance et la dernière le
dernier en date qui fait encore l'objet
de question au gouvernement là-dessus
hier c'est effectivement le le data hub
donc ce ce gigantesque
agrégateur de données de santé dont même
tous les spécialistes disent que c'est
un cadeau infini qui vient d'être fait à
Microsoft. Monsieur Sicar a eu
l'occasion de se prononcer récemment
là-dessus, spécialiste de l'éthique
médicale et et beaucoup de
parlementaires de tous les bords, y
compris de la majorité, se sont se sont
déclarés hostilees à ce principe. Donc
je crois que on doit on doit réfléchir
autrement. Je veux dire, on doit pas
simplement essayer de d'infléchir un
tout petit peu la courbe. On doit se
dire que un, nous devons créer une
industrie européenne et nous en avons
les cerveaux, nous en avons les
secteurs, les filières. On en a ilan
leune que cita que cité taric tout à
l'heure dirige le le pôle intelligence
artificielle de de de Facebook mais on
pourrait citer bien d'autres dans la
silicone vallée français ingénieur de
très haut niveau. On a largement les
talents. Simplement on n' pas articulé
une politique comme on l'avait fait dans
les années 60 70 sur des secteurs
stratégiques aussi bien dans le
transport que dans l'énergie que dans le
justement dans le calcul dans les
technologies. On ne l'a pas fait et
effectivement il y a une sorte de
renoncement progressif qui s'est de de
résignation qui s'est installée. Cette
résignation n'est pas une fatalité du
tout du tout.
Je me parle juste il y a un paradoxe
incroyable. permets-toi et prends ton
temps.
Un paradoxe incroyable en fait, c'est
que les deux technologies de domination
du web à la fois par la Chine et par les
États-Unis ont été inventés en Europe.
Europe en France même
Linux et le web
et le web et
mais vas-y surprise
et et TCPIP c'est la brique fondamentale
de l'internet
bien sûr
au dire même de Vinton Surf a été
élaboré conceptualisé par un certain
Louis Pousin très peu connu des Français
mais qui a été l'architecte des premiers
réseaux avec des datagrammes avec cyclad
et cetera donc typiquement il a même été
récompensé par la reine d'Angleterre
pour sa contribution à l'internet donc
je veux dire on se rend compte que nous
avons laissé s'est passé et le web a été
inventé au CERN à Genève dans un
laboratoire européen. Je veux dire
toutes ces technologies nous n'en avons
rien fait. Alors que
c'est pas qu'on en a rien fait, c'est
que on a euh
il faut voir qu'il y a des derrière la
technologie, il y a des idéologies, il y
a plusieurs et
j'en profite pour te poser une question.
Les plateformes dominantes ont-elles des
biaiss idéologiques ?
justement euh alors aroliquement parce
que en ce moment je m'intéresse, je
reviens aux fondamentaux à l'histoire de
la technologie, se dire pourquoi on est
là, pourquoi on est on est là, je veux
dire avec des plateformes comme les
comme les G femmes d'un côté et de
l'autre côté le les plateformes
chinoises.
Il y a il y a plusieurs choses. La
première, c'est d'un point de vue de la
technologie, on a deux visions qui se
sont toujours euh opposées. La première,
c'était l'idée que la machine sert à
augmenter l'être humain. Donc c'est un
une vision humaniste. C'est des doule
bars, c'est le type qui a inventer tout,
le desktop, la souris, il était il était
à Stanford et et donc sa vision c'est de
dire l'ordinateur alors ça Steve Jobs le
disait très bien, il disait Bicycle for
the Mind, un vélo pour l'esprit. C'est
qu'en fait on était capable grâce à la
machine de faire plus. Et de l'autre
côté, à peu près à 500 m plus loin à
Stanford, il y avait John McCarty, l'un
des inventeurs de l'intelligence
artificielle et sa vision c'était la
machine va remplacer le cerveau humain.
Et ces deux visions en fait on sont
tombé courts parce que il a fallu
attendre le Mcintos pour que la vision,
on va dire, de l'interface
se développe et il a fallu attendre des
années pour que la vision de
l'intelligence artificielle décolle. ça
les pipes de données pour pouvoir
entraîner ton intelligence artificielle.
C'est ça. Et et ce qui est drôle, c'est
que dans une conversation que j'avais eu
euh euh privée avec un des des deux
fondateurs de de Google, il le dit assez
ouvertement. Alors, je l'ai jamais
entendu dire publiquement, mais il le
que l'A c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont
découvert. Ils ont découvert à partir à
un moment donné qu'avec toutes les
données qu'ils avaient, ils pouvaient
faire des choses. Ça n'a jamais été
quelque chose qui a été pensé parce que
Google était plutôt dans la vision très
utilitaire. euh de de la de l'internet.
Donc on a une question, une réponse, on
est capable de de répondre. C'est
c'était l'internet euh euh de tout ce
qui était pratique.
Euh ce qui ce qui s'est passé, c'est que
quand on quand d'un point de vue de
l'idéologie politique, par contre, on a
trois visions. Euh, on a une vision
américaine, une vision russe et une
vision européenne. La vision américaine,
c'est la vision des libertariens.
C'est celle qui a donné finalement 30 40
ans plus tard Facebook. C'est moi en
tant qu'individu, l'informatique me
donne le pouvoir d'être un individu.
Alors ce qui est curieux c'est que cette
vision a été totalement effacée puisque
maintenant Facebook c'est le pouvoir
d'être un individu a quasiment disparu.
De l'autre côté on a eu une alors
pendant les années 60, c'est c'est
fascinant parce que il y a se développe
ce qu'on appelait la cybernétique. Donc
la cybernétique se développe notamment
chez les militaires parce qu'ils
s'étaient intéressés à l'idée
d'automatiser les les plein de choses
mais en notamment les missiles mais en
Russie il y a eu une ce qu'on appelait
la cybernétique sociale et je suis en
train de découvrir des choses
incroyables. Notamment cette personne
exceptionnelle s'appelle Anatolie Kitof
qui a compris très tôt que la vision en
fait de la cybernétique sociale c'était
d'algorithmiser le plan quinquenal. Donc
la la Russie euh organisait des plans,
planifier tout et on s'est dit on va
utiliser la machine pour organiser les
gens. En fait, c'était la vision de
Facebook et de Google aujourd'hui 40 ans
avant. Mais ça a été aussi euh pas au 40
ans, qu'est-ce que je dis ? C'était les
années 60 mais c'est la vision qui a été
exportée ensuite en Chine et qui a à mon
avis est le un des fondements
idéologiques du crédit social. La
technologie doit servir non pas à
manipuler les gens individuellement, ce
qui est le cas de Facebook, mais de
construire une forme d'harmonie
technologique en identifiant les les
mauvais et bons comportements. En Chine,
on vous dit voilà, tu ne peux pas faire
ça. Si tu vas tard le soir acheter une
une bouteille de jean, ben tu ton crédit
baisse. C'est cette idée qu'on va gérer
la la l'ensemble de la population alors
que la vision de Facebook et une vision
plus libertarienne, c'était l'individu.
Et en Europe, on l'oublie dans les
années 90, il y a une vision
communautaire. Cette idée que la
technologie doit servir à l'ensemble de
la société. C'est une vision qui démarre
avec le Chaos Computer Club en Allemagne
dans les années 80 qui a Linux, c'est
exactement ça. C'est on développe des
choses et on les met à disposition. le
web, le je rappelle que le web c'est pas
de pattern, pas de patente, rien. C'est
le le tout le monde peut l'utiliser. Et
donc cette idée que nous allons créer la
technologie qui va servir au bien-être
de l'ensemble. Le problème, c'est que
cette vision qui est fantastique, qui
est une vision moi qui m'a toujours oui.
Voilà, on a à un moment donné, on a dit
"Ah, on est nul, on a nul, on va on va
laisser on va laisser cette vision." Et
ce qui moi me dérange le plus, c'est pas
tellement la question de technologie, la
technologie, on peut toujours mettre des
gens bons, mais pour faire quoi ? Et
aujourd'hui, ce que l'Europe doit
montrer, notamment sur les questions de
données, c'est comment on construit
quelque chose qui est bénéfique à
l'ensemble. Et ça, malheureusement, on a
échoué. On a échoué technologiquement,
on a échoué idéologiquement, on a échoué
politiquement. Il y a plein de plein de
de raisons pour lesquelles on pourra
qu'on pourra discuter. Mais on a échoué
pour moi, c'est le véritable échec. Et
la question de la souveraineté euh elle
est pas uniquement technologique. C'est
pas dire on va on va pas héberger nos
données. C'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on
doit collecter les données ? pour quoi
faire et quel est le bénéfice court
terme, moyen terme et long terme. Et ça
c'est une conversation qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à à faire à faire ouvrir.
Oui. C'est-à-dire que de la même manière
qu'il y a quelques années, on a eu des
débats sur la bioéthique qui
passionnaient non seulement les les
parlementaires mais même les Français
parce qu'effectivement ils étaient
capables d'identifier les sujets sur la
filiation, sur le les manipulations
génétiques. Ils étaient très vite
impliqués. Or, les débats sur les
technologies sont plus compliqués à
faire comprendre à un large public et
pour avoir été de ceux qui ont tenté de
le faire, on se rend bien compte de la
difficulté, mais je crois qu'on est en
train progressivement d'avoir des gens
qui demandent à comprendre et on voit
que globalement euh je pense qu' en plus
c'est étrangement puisquon on parlait
effectivement de de du crédit social,
étrangement l'étape d'après maintenant
pour le pour le régime chinois, c'est
établir une cartographie génétique total
de la population
comme a pu le le montrer le New York
Times il y a pas longtemps. Et
typiquement, on va donc passer du crédit
social au génome social où on va passer
pour les amateurs de science-fiction de
minority report à Gataka ou un mix des
deux. Et c'est et c'est ça que nous
devons nous conjurer. Pourquoi nous
européens avons été si méfiants par
rapport à la NSA dans le cadre de enfin
quand je dis nous européens, je devrais
dire précisément plus nos amis allemands
que nous-mêmes français sensibles à ces
questions parce que justement il y avait
un passé de stasie, d'écoute et cetera
et euh et et sur les manipulations
génétiques parce qu'il y avait aussi une
idéologie qui avait il y a 70 80 ans de
ça était terrible par rapport à cette
idée de race supérieure et cetera. Et
donc on voit bien que les mécanismes de
défense que nous avons nous par rapport
à la vie privée n'existent pas du tout
de la même manière aux États-Unis où
elle est pas du tout codifiée de la même
manière, protégée de la même manière.
Cit c'est un droit du consommateur la
vie privée aux États-Unis. pour nous
européens, c'est un droit fondamental,
c'est un droit élémentaire de l'humain.
Et bien, je crois effectivement que
c'est cette visionlà qu'on doit
justement essayer de faire valoir et euh
et effectivement ce peut-être euh un
certain Paul Nemitz qui s'occupe des
affaires juridiques de la Commission
européenne disait
peut-être que que la protection des
données deviendra pour les années
2010-2020 ce que l'écologie a été dans
les années 80 et auparavant.
C'est-à-dire un au départ ça
apparaissait comme politiquement farfelu
l'écologie dans le tout début euh
aujourd'hui ça paraît indispensable. Et
bien de la même manière ce qui nous
paraît encore difficile parce qu'on se
dit interdire le microciblage, éviter
effectivement ces concentrations de
pouvoir infinie autour de quelques
sociétés américaines ou chinoises
puisqu'elle est deux maintenant. Euh
typiquement ça paraît difficile mais de
fait on voit bien que c'est le seul
chemin possible parce que sinon c'est la
tenaille sino-américaine avec d'un côté
effectivement euh une dérive totale
autour des des des sociétés qui
accumulent les données et de l'autre
côté un régime chinois qui accumule je
dirais des outils de surveillance de
contrôle de de d'ingénierie sociale de
plus en plus inquiétant et et
effectivement on le y compris sur des
minorités ethniques avec des
comportements puisque parmi les les
individus qui seraient le plus
directement ciblés d'après ce que
Exactement les minorités ethniques et
religieuses. Donc on voit bien que là il
y a il y a je dirais un basculement
parce que en gros on voit qu'il y a un
risque bien au-delà de la seule sphère
économique.
Mais le je vais me faire l'avocat du
diable. Donc bingo un point c'est un
truc entre nous. Euh la je me fais
l'avocat du diable, le régime chinois de
de du flicage par crédit social,
ça va séduire beaucoup de politiciens.
Ça séduit déjà. Ça séduit déjà.
C'est-à-dire à l'heure actuelle les ce
qu'on appelle les démocraties libérales,
peu importe,
c'est effectivement des individus qui
ont très bien compris l'usage qu'il
pourrait faire d'un système de ce genre.
Euh simplement, il se trouve que euh je
dirais la Chine euh a un avantage entre
guillemets compétitif par rapport à ça,
c'est qu'elle est capable de le déployer
sur un/4 de l'humanité, un petit peu
moins d'un/art de l'humanité. Donc par
définition, c'est un un angle d'attaque
qui est infiniment plus grand. Mais que
des gens dans les équipes, par exemple
de Trump et et de Bolsonaro soient
fascinés par des outils de contrôle
social, c'est pas une nouveauté. C'est
pas une nouveauté. C'est-à-dire que
quelque part la volonté d'éteindre toute
forme de contestation euh de manière
radicale voire violente comme ça pu se
faire ces derniers temps
en France
en France parfois parfois mais qui qui a
une fascination technologique qui est
une forme d'ubrise technologique sur le
fait de dire et c'est d'ailleurs
peut-être pour ça la raison de la
complaisance dont on parlait par rapport
effectivement à ces sociétés c'est qu'il
y a une forme de fascination pas
simplement économique ou libérale non
non non c'est aussi une fascination sur
la la capacité effectivement de pouvoir
et d'influence. Et donc pour un
politique, avoir une influence absolue
sur les individus,
pour un politique, je dirais modestement
armé d'un point de vue moral, c'est
quelque chose de très tentant. Je donne
toujours, si je peux me permettre
là-dessus, une anecdote. Euh, j'étais à
la conférence sur l'intelligence
artificielle et juste avant que notre
président Emmanuel Macron,
notre suprême leader,
suprême leader si tu veux, évoque le
sujet, "Mon téléphone vibre, je prends
mon téléphone et c'était une
notification de Facebook pour m'annoncer
ce que j'allais voir et je me suis dit
waouh, on est en fait effectivement dans
cette idée." Alors, le problème du
politique et c'est en général vrai aussi
pour toute la question euh du numérique
en France. Là, je prends quelques
instants ma mon ancienne casquette de
vice-président du Conseil national du
numérique, c'est que le numérique en
France, c'est de la com. Donc déjà,
malheureusement tous nos tous nos
ministres ont fait sciences pot HC.
Donc, il faut c'est si on fait pas ça,
on n'est pas ministre et surtout on a
une vision extrêmement
communicationnelle. Donc c'est les
réseaux sociaux, le buzz, le clash. Et
ce qui est fascinant, c'est que on leur
donne l'illusion de de ce pouvoir. Je
pense que Facebook, Twitter ont choisi
d'ailleurs, je crois que les deux ont
choisi des éarques comme donc ça montre
que comme lobbiste mais aussi comme
patron. Donc ça montre qu'il y avait un
ils avaient très bien compris comment
aborder le marché.
Mais surtout, il y a cette idée du de
cette illusion
du du pouvoir, du nombre de followers de
de la course contre la montre. Et en
fait ce qu'on fait quand on quand on est
politique et qu'on on diffuse des
messages sur Facebook, on améliore le
ranking de ces plateforme. Donc en fait,
on améliore le micro targeting. Donc en
fait en ayant l'impression d'avoir un
acte citoyen ou en tout cas un acte un
pouvoir,
on oublie qu'en fait on alimente en
donné en en clic en le simple fait de
regarder, de ne pas regarder, de
regarder 20 secondes un un discours.
Tout ça, ce sont des informations qui
vont pas être utilisées par les partis
politiques parce que si on demande à à
tous les partis politiques français,
est-ce que vous avez des informations
très précises sur l'usage de vos
internautes, ils en ils en savent ils
savent pas. Mais par contre, Facebook a
collecté toutes ces données et vont s'en
servir derrière pour du retargeting
publicitaire. Euh donc en fait, on a on
a aussi un un un un un problème
essentiel, c'est qu'on a pas compris.
Faudit, je sais que euh je pense que tu
as tu as dû le faire. On essayer de
d'expliquer au aux politiques que le
numérique ça va au-delà de la com, il
faut il faut comprendre l'algorithmie,
il faut comprendre un certain nombre de
de choses assez basique hein. Il faut
même pas aller dans les détails.
Déjà discuté avec Cédrico.
Euh non, je le connais pas euh mais je
l'ai je l'ai vu je l'ai vu sur votre
excellente émission. Euh euh mais euh je
euh on a eu on a eu beaucoup alors alors
ce qui était intéressant avec le le le
Sénum, c'est qu'on voyait beaucoup de
politiques
conseil conseil national du numérique.
Euh on voyait beaucoup de politiques, on
était censé normalement recevoir les
lois à vent qu'elle qu'elle qu'ell
sortent et qu'elle soit ell on devait
donc conseiller le gouvernement. On les
a quasiment tout eu sauf celles sur la
loi la loi la loi sur renseignement
comme par hasard. n'est pas elle n'est
pas passée par nous. Euh et c'est là
après que j'ai compris qu'on avait euh
alors euh alors on parlait de filière
numérique, c'est vrai qu' en France, on
a quand même une filière sur la
surveillance qui est consistante à
travers les âges. Euh sur les autres, on
n' jamais eu de vision à long terme.
C'est-à-dire que dès qu'on a un nouveau
ministre ou dès qu'on a un nouveau
gouvernement, il y a une nouvelle
dynamique. Alors, on a eu la la start-up
nation en ce moment qui est plus ou
moins à mon avis un peu arrivé à la à la
à la fin parce que
la bullshit nation, non ? Ben le moi je
suis un moi je suis un fan des des des
j'ai toujours été fan des start-ups
puisque quand j'étais tout jeune j'étais
fasciné par Steve Jobs par Comodore par
toutes ces boîtes d'entrepreneurs. C'est
fantastique.
H
et en France on a ce ce biaet ce
travers, je sais pas comment dire. On
institutionnalise ou on a
institutionnalisé le rap, la techno,
donc toutes les cultures les plus
underground et la start-up qui est quand
même un truc de rebelle à la base de
gens qui n'ont pas fait d'études de
dropout. En France, c'est devenu
l'inverse, c'est d'une certaine manière
la la continuité d'une forme de voilà
d'élite d'élite social où on donne
immédiatement à des à des gamins qui
sortent de l'école des statuts de cadre
sup. Euh et il y a ça et puis de l'autre
côté, il y a tous les autres qui sont
nés du mauvais côté de l'écran.
C'est-à-dire que eux, c'est un pixel qui
se déplace sur des livros ou sur Uber et
eux n'ont même pas le droit de au à la
retraite à des choses basique. Donc on a
on a aussi construit un système qui
montre ses limites. Alors aux
États-Unis, c'est un peu normal parce
que là on on découvre avec la crise du
Covid que le système explose
complètement.
Même si vous avez Amazon là qui est en
train de faire une chose assez
incroyable, ils ont dit "On va on va
faire un système de e-commerce
complètement COVID free. On va donc on
va on va vraiment travailler à à
optimiser la chaîne au développement et
ils profitent aujourd'hui en en 3 mois,
ils ont quasiment annilé tous leurs
concurrents. À part Walmart, il y a plus
personne qui peut leur faire de la
concurrence. Euh c'est pareil que
Netflix hein qui a évidemment on sait
que le le on sait que Cann est toujours
opposé aux films qui vont passer sur
Netflix, on les met pas. Et là, cette
année, on demande à Netflix, Amazon, je
ne sais qui d'autre en streaming de
mettre de mettre tout en de tout en
ligne. Donc, on a euh on a ce ce
problème euh c'est qu'effectivement à
chaque fois qu'on on veut euh euh d'un
point de vue politique avancer dans une
direction, euh donc euh euh là la
start-up nation avec Hollande, c'est pas
c'est pas clair. Pour moi, Hollande ça a
été alors je mais Sarkozi je pense que
il savait pas trop c'était les débuts
mais à l'époque d'Hollande on savait on
savait pour Snowden, on savait pour la
gaff les les plateformes.
Et pourquoi ? Pourquoi ? parce que Axel
le maire
euh elle ou mais mais mais mais Fleur
Pellerin aussi les deux en fait ont eu
un un un je vais pas dire un double
discours. Euh il fallait dire qu'on fait
les choses et en même temps en coulisse
on a laissé la fameuse ligne rouge dont
on parlait c'est des choses qui
n'auraient pas dû être faites.
Je vais donner une une anecdote.
son nom m'échappe. Mais tu vas peut-être
euh l'ancien patron de LANC qui est
maintenant le directeur technique
non maintenant
Pard c'est maintenant celui qui était
juste avant lui.
Ah celui qui était vraiment coincé qui
qui se prenait pour
mais qui était qui est maintenant à la
direction de technique de la DGSE.
Voilà. On avait donc il y avait une
réunion et et ben il a la direction de
la DGSE lui
technique je crois technique
heureusement. Et donc euh on avait
discuté et on a parlé de plateforme et
immédiatement en fait il a le le
discours est parfaitement redire mais
j'ai eu aussi une conversation avec
Poupard que j'ai trouvé mieux d'ailleurs
que moi j'ai pas jeai mais j'ai trouvé
les deux excellents sur le sur le
discours
et sauf que j'ai appris que Pupar était
aussi excellent en crypto et donc ça lui
rend c'est quelqu'un que j'ai trouvé de
très sympathique déjà mais qui en plus
est vraiment une brute épaisse dans dans
ces domaines. Donc il est il est pas
c'est pas un touriste, mais leur
discours sur la la question de la
souveraineté, sur la question des
plateformes, sur la était pas un
discours naïf. Et je le la première
question que je leur pose à chaque fois,
c'est est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui vous
écoutent ? Est-ce que vous avez la
moindre influence ? Parce qu'aujourd'hui
euh moi je je préférais que quelqu'un
comme Poupard soit un ministre du mec.
Mais juste pour l'anecdote, le précédent
avant Poupard, je l'avais attrapé à
l'école de guerre, je lui avais posé une
question sur les hackurs. Il m'a dit en
gros qu'il en avait rien à [__] des
hackurs. Ah ! Tu vois, tu vois le niveau
Bernard.
Non, non, je crois je crois
effectivement qu'il y a qu'il y a eu un
problème d'éducation et d'accompagnement
du politique par rapport à ces
questions. Et pour être militant dans
ces domaines depuis longtemps, je vois
bien la difficulté. C'est je rejoins
l'idée que trop souvent ça a été vécu
comme un outil cosmétique et donc en
lieu et place de mettre une coordination
sur les différents sujets clés
sécurité, éducation, culture et cetera
et d'avoir comme ça s'est fait sous le
l'er Obama un un chief technology
officer, c'està-dire quelqu'un qui
coordonne les technologies fédérales, on
a à chaque fois les gens en silo et donc
par définition on n' pas effectivement
une prise en main de ces questions.
au niveau où elle le mériterait. Et donc
on a on a laissé effectivement dériver
progressivement ces sujets et surtout on
s'est absten voire même c'est devenu un
mot tabou de fait de dire il nous faut
créer des conditions de politique
industrielle enfin des des des
orientations de politique industrielle
alors même que comme tout à l'heure
Taric évoquait les grands entrepreneurs
de la Silicone Vallée je citerai une
autre économiste Mariana Mazukato qui
disait il y a pas une seule des
technologies clé de l'iPhone qui n'est
de près ou de loin moi était financé par
des crédits fédéraux américains
et français puisque ST a pendant
longtemps été dans la F.
Même tor avait été financé.
Bien sûr. Donc par définition tout à
l'heure
pourquoi tu rigoles Taric ? parce que je
tu rigoles la même chose que moi. C'est
ça.
Ouais. Voilà. Donc donc par définition,
on se rend compte que là où aux
États-Unis on a créé aider des Elon Musk
avec des contrats d'état de la NASA, on
a aidé toutes les grandes entreprises à
se développer avec des des des crédits
et des et des commandes fédérales et
locales. Nous en France dès que l'on
parlez le mot que l'on agite maintenant
c'est le Small Business Act. Small
Business Act, c'est l'orientation d'une
partie de la commande publique, donc de
l'argent du contribuable vers des
petites sociétés. ce qui se fait aux
États-Unis depuis plus de 50 ans. Mais
c'est pas compliqué. Dès que vous en
parlez, vous avez une vision, je dirais
quasiment dogmatique, certains dirai de
du de le hordolibéralisme qui est de
dire "Ah non, non, là vous êtes en train
de vous en prendre à la à l'équilibre du
marché, donc il faut surtout pas et bien
non, aux États-Unis ça a fonctionné." Je
dirais leur interventionnisme est un de
leurs secrets les mieux cachés. C'est
qu'ils essayent de mettre en avant des
figures charismatiques, Steve Jobs,
anciennement Bill Gates ou d'autres en
en en gommant toute l'action
gouvernementale pour essayer justement
de leur donner des armes des armes le
plus tôt possible pour ça. Non,
je voulais juste revenir là-dessus parce
que je suis absolument d'accord avec ce
point. Quand on lors d'une d'un débat
sur le Data Hub, j'avais écouté notre
ex-ministre du numérique Cédric
parler de mais vous imaginez euh Amazon
il mettent je crois il parlait de 20
milliards dans le cloud par
s'appelle ministre on ne sait pas
20 milliards dans le cloud
20 milliards dans le cloud on peut pas
faire on peut pas faire
ça été repris hier par d'ailleur
absolument euh on peut pas faire on peut
pas on peut pas s'opposer à ça la
réalité
c'est que je pense que c'est les gens
qui ont une vision extrêmement libérale
à la française qui pensent que le marché
est parfait. Le marché s'ils sont là,
c'est parce qu'ils sont bons. Mais on
oublie que on a enlevé les taxes sur le
e-commerce
que l'IPO alors un copain qui a fait
l'IPO d'Amazon il y a il y a il y a 20
ans.
Entré en bourse, ils avaient levé 85
millions, c'est rien.
Ils ont transformé ça en une machine de
guerre incroyable. Bon, je pense que
Jeff Bezos est fondamentalement là
aujourd'hui le vivant l'entrepreneur le
plus impressionnant. Euh moi, je préfère
à à Elon Mus, même si je pense qu'il est
très malin et très impressionnant, euh
parce qu'il a construit un empire, mais
il l'a construit parce avec l'aide de
l'État américain, avec la diplomatie
américaine, je rappelle la diplomatie
américaine qui demande à Twitter de ne
pas mettre à jour le au moment de la de
la de la des des troubles et la
révolution en Iran. euh du fait que
l'État est derrière euh évidemment le on
je sais que vous avez fait l'émission
sur le sur le sur le sur le cloud act
mais toutes les la régulation et la
réglementation est faite au service des
boîtes américaines.
Eric Schmid vient de quitter d'ailleurs
enfin il a quitté Google et maintenant
il est conseiller du Pentagone
et il a publié alors ça je ça vous
pouvez le trouver facilement sur
internet un document PDF d'une de 80
pages
sur la le risque de la de la de la Chine
euh en tant que parce qu'on est en
guerre froide technologique avec la
Chine depuis que Trump est arrivé. Alors
on était un peu mais là c'est un peu
plus visible. Euh et c'est fascinant
parce que quand vous lisez ce document
euh vous dites il y a je sais pas s'il y
a quelqu'un en France qui aurait été
capable de faire quelque chose d'ussi
bon, mais surtout on on prend conscience
euh euh de du fait qu'on est dans une
dans une logique où les États-Unis sont
derrière toutes leurs entreprises. Donc
quand
où les entreprises américaines font
partie du bras armé de la diplomatie et
de la politique américaine. Non mais
donc on est je juste là est-ce que vous
avez lu Raymond Aaron un peu non
dans autre temps. Oui,
un peu moins. Moi je mais je j'ai vu et
euh je voulais simplement dire que si
ces sociétés sont là où elles sont,
elles sont là parce qu'elles sont très
bonnes mais parce que la machine
américaine euh et c'est normal leur a
enlevé toutes les contraintes.
Ah il y a un problème de taxe. On vous
enlève les taxes.
Fiscalisation
direct indirect. Donc on a véritablement
aujourd'hui quand euh
et en échange, on garde une petite main
à l'intérieur.
Alors, j'ai j'ai posé la question à
j'avais un un ami qui était direct qui
était directeur de la sécurité chez
Google avant après est allé chez
Intercept euh et il m'a raconté que
il était chez Intercept pour faire des
enquêtes.
Non non. Euh et euh euh et il
m'expliquait comment ça marche. Alors en
fait euh chez Google Facebook, il y a
des gens beded donc des des gens des
renseignements, mais ils sont choisis
par les les HR. C'estàd qu'en fait ils
ont pas le ils peuvent pas prendre
n'importe qui. Ils ont besoin d'avoir
des gens habilités mais ils ont un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont là
qui ne reportent qu'au CEO et qui et qui
donc exécutent les fameuses requêtes
FISA que que qui sont donc les les
fameuses requêtes qui sont demandées
pour accéder à les données. Et donc ils
font ça. Il y a effectivement un
contingent de gens.
Alors après c'est un système qui qui est
un peu limite mais qui est légal. Mais
ce qu'ils ont fait simplement, c'est que
il y a des juges qu'on peut appeler à
n'importe quelle heure de la journée. On
peut leur demander autant de requêes
qu'on veut et il signe. Enfin, c'est
quasiment automatisé mais c'est enfin
c'est contrôlé et après c'est euh c'est
c'est contrôlé. Euh disons que ça en
tout cas tel qu'on l'a expliqué c'est
euh c'est c'est officiel. C'estàd que
plein de gens savent. Alors les employés
ne savent pas qui c'est évidemment, mais
le les patrons donc les à l'époque la
page enfin le Mark Zuckenberg et et les
autres savent donc ça mais ça a toujours
je dirais d'une certaine manière la
relation entre le militaire, le
renseignement
et l'internet a toujours été
relativement
dis-moi
souple.
Quand tu en repè un, tu gagnes un
t-shirt ou pas ? Peut-être
avec parquet Spot de Fed.
Spot de Fed de Spot. de Fed, mais je me
rappellerai on il y a des années, on
dans une conférence de hackur et non
hacking in progress en euh en c'était en
Hollande organisé par le groupe de
pirates qui s'appelait XS for all, des
types fantastiques
où on a rencontré plein de gens et et
donc les gens qui étaient faisaient
partie de la NSA parce qu'il y en avait
pas mal, il devaient avoir un badge
orange, il y en a plein qui n'avaient
pas mis le badge orange et donc il
fallait spotter les et à la fin ils ont
tous été détectés. Euh et à l'époque, on
avait fait une conférence avec
sur le échelon, une enfin un petit truc,
on était une quinzaine, il y a trois
types qui sont venus un peu plus âgés et
qui nous ont dit "Non, c'est pas
exactement comme ça. C'est c'était
fascinant parce que moi ce qui m'a
toujours fasciné dans la dans la NSA,
parce que j'ai c'est un sujet qui m'a
qui me fascine depuis presque milieu des
années 80, c'est comment on est capable
de d'analyser autant d'information, de
stocker autant d'information." C'est que
si le savoir-faire de la NSA était
utilisé dans les bibliothèques, je dans
un dans un dans une vision un peu plus
positive, c'est incroyable. C'estàd que
il faut pas oublier que Next, qui était
la boîte de Steve Job dont tout le monde
pensait qu'elle était morte, euh en fait
elle vendait toutes ses machines à la
SIA, la NSA, elle avait pas le droit de
le dire. Donc quand ils ont été rachetés
par Apple, on a fini par rendre se
rendre compte que que ce que ça a
fonctionné. Donc des gens comme Steve
Job vendait à la à la à la à ses
agences. Euh Google a eu des des
financements puisque après le 11
septembre, quasiment tout l'argent est
parti dans le dans le euh
contre terrorisme
contre terrorisme d'analy sémantique
tous ces outils. Donc tout le monde
s'est positionné d'ailleurs, pas lentir
d'une certaine manière un peu profiter
euh euh de ça. Euh mais mais Google
aussi Google aussi ont eu des
subventions.
Je trouve que le type full disclosure,
le type qui avait fait qui a financé qui
a créé Incutel le fond
euh
un de mes investisseurs quand je faisais
quand je faisais NES Vibe, c'était
devenu le le général partter de de
d'Axel. Axel qui était investisseur de
Facebook de plein de plein d'autres
boîtes. Donc il y a
pardon non mais il y avait il y a donc
il y a toujours eu des relations mais il
y a toujours eu des relations plutôt
business parce que comme vous le savez
aux États-Unis le budget du Pentagone
est je vais même pas dire astronomique
parce que c'est
donc tout le monde et a commencé par des
nouveaux les nouveaux les palentir et
les autres ce qu'on appelle le nouveau
consortium militaire industriel ils ont
qu'une vue c'est euh c'est c'est prendre
une part de gâteau. le projet Jedi qui
devait normalement venir à Amazon et qui
est arrivé à Microsoft, c'était 10
milliards.
Faut que tuexpliques ce que c'est le
projet de Jedi. Tu veux euh non
en gros ça a donné lieu ça a donné lieu
à un procès ce qui est quand même assez
inhabituel de la part d'un géant
américain qui du fait de l'exclusion
manifestement dirigée contre eux par
Trump a porter plainte contre le
Pentagone vous imaginez donc une grande
société porter plainte contre le
Pentagone et effectivement réussir à à
geler la chose et donc c'est alors
juste pour répondre Jedi c'était le le
projet de cloud du Pentagone c'est c'est
voilà c'est
sur sur ces sur ces sujets je vous
recommande l'excellent ouvrage de Shane
Harris
s'appelle at war at war avec le a war
sur le lobby binetaro internet et donc
c'est une belle une belle description de
l'histoire des liens entre les deux mais
j'allais dire quelque part on a tendance
spontanément à se dire c'est mal oui et
non je dirais que les militaires
historiquement ai été à vide de
nouvelles technologies c'est vrai dans
tous les pays que les innovations, je
citais tout à l'heure le le les
innovations de l'iPhone depuis le
tactile, l'intelligence artificielle, le
le système Siri et cetera et d'abord été
développé dans des enceinte militair à
des fins militaires. On rappellera quand
même que les les premiers essais sur la
visée tête haute, les interfaces en
réalité augmenté, c'était des systèmes
militaires pour les pilotes d'avion.
Donc par définition, je veux dire euh
c'est à partir du moment où on a des
budgets qui sont hors de contrôle, comme
on est en train de s'interroger même aux
États-Unis maintenant sur le fait qu'il
soit hors de contrôle, euh que le
problème se pose mais que les militaires
puissent être dans le cadre d'une
politique industrielle intelligemment
conçue à l'origine et accompagné des
sociétés et des technologies dans ces
domaines. En tant que tel, ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas choquant. La preuve en est,
on rappellera pour ceux qui l'auraient
qui qui auraient vécu dans une cave ces
50 dernières années que l'internet est
né de projet du département de la
recherche militaire américaine. D'acord
il y a 30 ans. Alors
oui oui, ceci est un propos que je ne
reprendrai pas. Un un politique un
politique récent a dit il y a 30 ans
naiss l'internet confondant le web et
internet.
Taric, combien de fois on a essayé de de
te recruter ?
Une fois.
C'était les Français ou c'était d'autres
français. Ouais,
quand même quand même quand même.
Je sais pas
euh j'étais j'étais à San Francisco et
euh avec un la personne qui m'héberge,
un un type fantastique qui a été un des
pionniers du MP3
et on avait un serveur donc on avait
d'ailleurs on avait des noms de domaines
assez cool à l'époque on avait encore
Ackurf.org qu'on a qu'on a perdu euh les
gars,
c'était en 96
et on avait on hébergeit le site Doroté
et il y a des gens qui sont venus
pirater le site qui ont réussi, ils ont
trouvé un ro kit et ils ont effacé plein
de choses dans tous mes mails
personnels. C'est une époque où j'étais
j'étais assez sensible à ces questions.
Alors à l'époque, j'étais j'étais je
travaillais chez Sun Microsystem, une
une filiale entre Sun et Thomson
et les types au-dessus c'était il y
avait Shimura, les Jawinskill, les gens
de
qui avaient travaillé sur notamment
Satan et donc on a essayé de faire la le
tracé inverse. On s'est rendu compte
qu'ils avaient ils étaient passés par le
le par le l'université au Texas.
Ensuite, on avait fait le le chemin
inverse
et ça m'a je sais pas pourquoi ça m'a
fasciné. J'avais jamais vraiment fait ça
et j'ai passé presque un mois et demi et
à la fin on a euh
Oui.
Mais je vais raconter l'histoire parce
que maintenant ça va être alors déjà on
se retrouve avec le le FBI parce que dès
lors que c'est un ça sort des c'est le
FBI était en fait l'équivalent à
travailler avec Interpol. Enfin c'est
devenu un truc multirés parce qu'ils
avaient fait ça dans plein d'autres
universités.
Euh bon, on est venu voir les les les
personnes avec avec Gill à l'époque. On
a amené les listings de des ils nous ont
demandé de poser des questions basiques
et la et donc on les suit donc voilà,
ils ont hacké tel serveur, ils sont
passés sur tel serveur, ils sont
repassés sur le serveur et la personne
qui était en face de nous parce qu'on
était dans une pièce avec évidemment un
micro, une videin et nous dit je vous
interromps ici, est-ce que ce qu'ils ont
fait est illégal ? À ce moment-là, il y
a on entend une porte ouverte, il y a
quelqu'un qui arrive et qui dit "I'm
gonna take it from there." Donc je
prends
et on a retrouvé alors la personne était
basée au Portugal mais en fait elle
était c'était un français et à la fin
bah je lui je l'ai eu au téléphone,
enfin j'ai eu sa mère qui m'a donné son
numéro de son dorm room, je l'ai appelé
et puis finalement j'ai rien fait parce
que qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que je pouvais
faire ? Par contre, une personne que je
nommerai pas parce que maintenant
malheureusement elle n'est plus elle
n'est plus avec nous avait eu son
serveur en France ha et lui a dit "Je
vais faire je vais porter plainte je
vais porter plainre." Je dit "Mais on a
on a tous eu 17 ans, on va pas le
faire." Et lui bah si il a quand même.
Et suite à ça, donc la personne qui
s'occupait de ça, le le policier dont le
nom m'échappe maintenant, qui s'occupait
de la brigade autour de ça, m'a dit
"Est-ce que vous voulez faire ce genre
de de boulot ?" et je lui ai répondu euh
non, ça ne me
Ils ont proposé combien ?
Ah non, mais c'était euh il m'a on est
pas on on en est pas arrivé là parce
qu'en fait il m'a dit "On aurait besoin
de gens comme vous de limier de". Je dis
"Me je suis pas un limier, je" c'est
juste qu'à un moment donné c'est un
quelque chose personnel qui est devenu
un espèce de d'obsession. J'ai appris
énormément plus j'allais voir les gens
au premier étage qui dis "Non, mais
est-ce que tu as pensé à ça C'est là que
j'ai découvert que l'internet, il y
avait des gens qui pouvaient aller deux
fois plus vite que la que la moyenne.
C'était encore, on était en 96, donc on
était vraiment à une période tout début
et moi ça m'avait ça m'avait fasciné.
Mais c'était pas mon c'était pas mon mon
sujet. Moi, j'aimais bien les questions
d'intelligence économique. J'en ai parlé
de temps en temps avec quelques
personnes des des des services comme ça,
mais c'est pas c'est pas mon c'est pas
mon c'est pas ma moi j'ai découvert
après alors je me suis beaucoup
intéressé à ces questions de hacking et
autres et à un moment donné j'en ai eu
marre. Je me suis rendu compte que si on
reste dans ce milieu, on devient on peut
plus vivre. Donc je me suis j'ai je suis
reparti sur des choses plus fun, la
musique en ligne, le MP3
qui est donné aussi après le piratage,
on a Dster toute cette période et et
après c'est une belle époque. Ouais,
c'est une époque qui me qui me manque
beaucoup parce que ce qu'on oublie c'est
que avant l'ordinateur était le nôtre,
c'était notre machine, notre disque dur,
nos fichiers.
Il y avait personne pour comptabiliser
le nombre de fois que j'ai écouté telle
musique qui peut d'ailleurs avoir une
application politique ou pas.
Donc il avait pas cette analyse, on
était dans un dans un univers où la
machine nous appartenait. C'est notre
forme de souveraineté personnelle. Et un
jour, on a dispersé les choses dans le
cloud et les gens qui avaient accès à
ces choses parce que quand on développe
et ça c'est pour ça que j'aime pas
l'idée de de simplifier d'algorithmie
quand on développe un projet, ce que
j'ai pu faire avec Net Vive, avec Jolie
Cloud, avec d'autres choses, on a un
pouvoir sur l'utilisateur. C'est
qu'aujourd'hui on peut faire croire à
l'utilisateur ce qu'on veut sur un
écran. On peut lui mentir, on peut lui
raconter des des beau bars, on peut le
manipuler et et ça c'est ça demande en
fait un un véritable forme d'humidité
qu'on a pas toujours et je pense que ce
qui s'est passé chez Facebook mais chez
Google et chez d'autres acteurs qu'ils
ont à un moment donné pété les plombs.
C'est qu'ils se sont dit on sait mieux
que les autres. Et quand vous regardez
les start-ups, c'est fascinant. Vous
avez souvent de gens très jeunes et
c'est volontaire parce qu'aux États-Unis
la différence de la France en en France
quand vous êtes développeur
et que vous restez développeur tard vous
êtes un loser alors qu'en fait aux
États-Unis vous êtes ce qu'on appelle un
senior développeur. James Goslin qui
avait enfin qui avait fait le Java
c'était un senior développeur. J'ai vu
des gens qui ont fait des bases de
données dans les années 60 70 ils sont
toujours bons. Leur cerveau fonctionne.
Ils avaient pas envie de manager
d'autres gens. Ils avaient envie d'être
dans leur passion. En France on n pas ça
malheureusement. Euh dès qu'on est euh
dès qu'on passe euh ce niveau, on passe
euh il faut qu'on devienne le manager.
Et là je perds un peu le fil de ce que
je veux dire. Est-ce que tu me regardes
?
C'est pas grave. Mais
Bernard
non moi j'aim
mais c'était très bien
non. Oui, je voulais juste revenir
là-dessus. Euh le contrôle, on a perdu
le contrôle de sa vie numérique et c'est
pour ça que maintenant je parle de de
beaucoup de Je sais pas si on aura le
temps de parler un peu de slow web. Si
je peux euh après
on fera ça après. Je vais laisser.
Donc termine termine si tu veux.
Non mais mais ce contrôle on l'a perdu
et aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucune
autorité de régulation capable de nous
redonner ce contrôle.
Souvent madame tu me dis tu es
nostalgique ? Je suis nostalgique d'un
temps. Bon déjà un temps où on pouvait
aller dans les aéroports sans avoir
voilà passer 2 heures avant ou après euh
à se poser des questions. Mais je suis
aussi nostalgique d'un temps où la
machine était un véritable compagnon.
C'était c'était un outil de confiance.
Moi moi ce qui m'a fasciné avec
l'ordinateur, c'est quand on est très
jeune et on a tous découvert son premier
ordinateur, la machine ne nous mens pas.
La machine fait ce qu'on lui demande. Il
y a cette relation unique que l'on
construit. Et aujourd'hui, quand on
démarre et que son premier ordinateur,
c'est en fait un iPhone, on a un outil
qui est déjà par définition perverti
commercialement. Et je trouve moi c'est
ça, je je trouve ça assez triste pour la
génération qui aujourd'hui découvre et
qui devrait apprendre qu'un ordinateur
ça se démonte, ça se décompile, ça se
s'analyse, ça se et et ça c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'on arrive à apprendre à à la à
la à la jeune génération.
Bernard, on voit là, je vote je vote
entièrement là-dessus. C'estàd dire que
on a on a arraché des mains des
utilisateurs. Vous savez, le principe
fondateur de l'internet, c'était le
principe du hand to. C'est-à-dire que
toutes les machines avaient les mêmes
droits, les mêmes devoirs sur le réseau
qu'on a appelé par la suite neutralité
du net. et et il se trouve effectivement
que maintenant on a recentralisé
euh autour de quelques plateformes le
pouvoir. Donc oui, effectivement essayer
d'éviter ça mais moi je dirais que la
traduction
politique de cette volonté c'est éviter
que les gars femmes ne deviennent non
pas omnipotent ce qu'ils sont mais
durablement omnipotent ce qu'il pourrait
être si on y prend pas garde. Et je
dirais que parmi les sociétés qui sont
moins connues des Français mais
certainement plus connus de vos
auditeurs, on parlait de pasir tout à
l'heure, le fait que les renseignements
intérieurs, donc la DGSI a reconduit
leur contrat avec une société qui a été
financée, conçue avec justement Inctel
sur les crédits de la CIA et très
directement mêlé à l'appareil de
renseignement américain et que ce soit
cette même société qui a essayé de gérer
les données Covid et qui qui l'a obtenu
d'ailleurs en Angleterre, la France a
refusé Alors, il faut préciser que que
quand Palentir s'approche de des
autorités, elle le fait en disant
qu'est-ce que c'est Palentir pour
pardon. Palantir, c'est la société
fondée pour analyser le big data dans la
lutte antiterroriste aux États-Unis. En
gros, c'est euh eux qui ont été les plus
à mêmes de développer un savoir-faire
unique auprès de quasiment la totalité
des agences de renseignement
américaines. Vous regardez la liste des
clients de parent, vous avez le gratin
du renseignement et de et des sphères
militaires américaines. Et donc
typiquement
qu'ils aient été choisis par la France
pour les renseignements antiterroristes
en France, c'est déjà une erreur que ça
a été reconduit en est une autre. Et et
effectivement là encore, moi je crois
que la solution essentielle c'est éviter
que ce genre de choses ne soit possible.
C'estàd que ça ne pose pas question dans
l'esprit d'un politique de gérer et de
et de faire gérer des données de ce
genre comme on en a parlé pour les
données de santé qui sont mais
infiniment cruciales pour les individus
surtout en période de pandémie.
Typiquement que ça n'est pas levé des
drapeaux rouges dans l'esprit des gens.
C'est preuve effectivement que il y a eu
une porosité, il y a eu une
complaisance, il y a eu une forme
effectivement de laisser faire et je
pense qu'il il y a des réponses
politiques. C'estàd que par rapport à
ces mastodontes que sont devenues les G
femmes qui ont perverti l'esprit
pionnier du web et de l'internet en
général,
je pense qu'il y a des solutions
politiques. Je je dirais je citerai un
politique qui parlait de toute autre
chose. Enfin donc qu'on a cité parlant
de toute autre chose. Mais en fait
c'était pas lui, c'était Moriac je
crois. Euh c'était j'aime tellement
l'Allemagne que j'aimerais qu'il y en
ait plusieurs. Euh et bien moi je crois
que j'aime tellement les G femmes que
j'aimerais qu'il soi divisé en tout
petit morceaux ou en ou être ou pour
être précis que ces sociétés ne puissent
pas en permanence utiliser leurs muscles
monopolistiques pour empêcher
effectivement toute forme d'existence
industrielle dans ces domaines.
Et pour ça, il faut un peu de courage
politique, c'est ça ? Non,
absolument. Il faut du muscle politique,
mais je dirais que là-dessus, plus les
temps se durcissent par rapport aux
questions d'opinion publique, de
radicalisation, plus le politique qui
rechignait aller sur des questions
industrielles de politique industrielle,
quand il est question de sa survie à
court terme dans le cadre électoral,
le politique tout d'un coup se se révèle
beaucoup plus réactif qu'on l'imaginait.
Donc là-dessus, je dirais que on a on a
on arrive à une période où effectivement
l'inaction aura une traduction politique
radicale et c'est le cas de le dire
radical.
Euh il y a trois quatre personnes qui
nous ont demandé de vous faire parler
autour de Aaron Schwartz ou Schwarz.
Schwarz,
ça dépend comment on le prononce.
Oui.
Taric.
Moi je le connaissais pas mal puisqu'on
a travaillé à l'époque de quand je
faisais Net Vive. qu'il était un il
était euh lié à la à la création de de
RSS, donc le le format de
euh de syndication des news. Euh bah
c'est quelqu'un que j'ai bah
c'est quelqu'un que j'ai évidemment
toujours apprécié. Euh d'une certaine
manière, ça a été alors euh c'est il y a
il y a plusieurs choses qui sont
tristes. Un, je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui était très euh un
hypersensible.
Euh c'est quelqu'un qui avait une vision
humaniste euh du monde.
C'est c'est une vision qui
quand on parle de MP3 de de Torrent de
Bit Torrent, moi ce qui me fascine
aujourd'hui c'est que la mémoire du
monde, la vraie mémoire du monde, les
films, les choses introuvables, les
choses quand on est cinéphile,
Netflix c'est sympa, mais c'est c'est
les soit c'est les séries Z de SF avec
des scénarios qu'on a déjà vu dans les
années 90, soit c'est des films des
années 90 qu'on a déjà vu 50 fois et
puis de temps en temps, il y a une ou
deux perles. Et le vrai la vraie mémoire
du monde, elle est en ligne. Elle se
cache derrière Pat B, derrière des
services comme cela. Et lui par rapport
au savoir scientifique, il avait aussi
cette vision et et c'est une vision que
j'ai toujours partagé parce que je pense
qu'à un moment donné dans l'humanité à
un moment t, il faudrait au moins que la
moitié du savoir soit librement
accessible. Le problème qu'on a
aujourd'hui, c'est que les brevets et
les et et les copyright durent de plus
en plus longtemps et le nombre de choses
que l'on produit sont de plus en plus
nombreuse. Donc en fait euh d'un point
de vue mathématique, le nombre de choses
qui sont librement accessibles euh se
réduisent et euh il a il pour
peut-être préciser comment il a
malheureusement terminé.
Oui, bien sûr. Mais euh euh et la
deuxième chose, c'est que je pense que
le MIT qui est quand même une
institution, bon c'est une institution
qui est aussi très fortement liée au
militaire puisquelle est née
au début ils ont fait les bâtards quand
même hein.
Ouais. euh
a mal joué et il a et a vraiment mal
joué en terme de je pense que c'est une
tâche, il y a ça, il y a l'histoire
évidemment avec Epstein, mais c'est une
vraie tâche et je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui bon l'internet a aussi
besoin d'héros. Euh c'est un c'est un
vrai héros parce qu' aussi il représente
la personne qui était pure. Et je je le
pense vraiment parce que on c'était pas
un intime mais c'était quelqu'un avec
qui j'ai discuté plusieurs fois que j'ai
vu quand j'étais aux États-Unis. euh qui
a quand même monté Redit, on l'oublie he
c'était quand même c'est que Alexis et
toute la bande, c'était les chaturs et
c'était lui en fait qui qui délivrait le
le truc euh qui est devenu aussi un
produit euh il avait cette vision pure
et je pense que il aimerait pas trop ce
que c'est devenu
et on a besoin de héros. On a d'un côté
Snowden aussi mais il y a il y a plein
de gens. Moi, moi j'aime moi je suis fan
de The Mentor qui était le manifeste
hackur
euh qui et puis aussi Tron qui était mon
hackeur préféré, un un allemand qui
avait craqué le le GSM dans les années
90 qui était aussi un personne pure,
c'estàd c'était un génie mais qui avait
vraiment le cœur pur et lui il avait
cette vision de la de la du savoir
technologique et de la de l'idée que la
technologie doit être au service de
l'humain,
non pas de l'humain, mais quand tu as
ça, mon père me le disait me le dis
toujours. C'est quand tu as un talent
particulier dans la vie, tu es très bon
dans un domaine. Si tu ne l'utilises pas
pour rendre le monde meilleur, en fait,
tu es tu es un peu un pauvre type. Et il
y a malheureusement beaucoup de gens qui
sont géniaux et qui font des trucs moi
qui me qui me donnent vraiment et
c'était pas le cas de c'était pas le cas
d'Aon, c'était vraiment c'était vraiment
quelqu'un d'incroyable.
Bernard, comment comment il a terminé ?
Malheureusement Malheureusement
l'histoire et c'est pour ça que c'est je
dirais c'est un héros foudroyé foudroyé
écrasé je dirais dans son dans dans son
dans son trajet et qui s'est
malheureusement suicidé
du fait poussé au suicid
qui a été alors voilà c'est s'est-il
fait suicider ? On peut pas le dire
ainsi, mais on peut dire simplement que
il a été acculé effectivement à cette
solution extrême alors même que
sincèrement, je dire tous ceux qui ont
eu l'occasion d'approcher, moi je
connais un de mes amis le connaissait
très bien certain Larry Lessig donc
qui qui a failli être juge mais qui a
refusé
voilà et il s'est trouvé effectivement
que lui-même puisque tout à l'heure
Taric parlait des commons, c'est c'est
commun comme on dit maintenant en
français c'est-à-dire ce ce patrimoine
libérement accessible lui-même a
beaucoup participé les sig a créé les
creatives commons qui ont permis
justement de de libérer un peu le le
carcan autour du du copyright américain
était un peu le parrain d'Aon
absolument et donc il a été il a été
véritablement écrasé par son par son
décès et j'ai je je dirais sans trahir
de secret il y a eu deux périodes où je
l'ai vu particulièrement déprimé d'une
part après le décès d'Alon Schwarz et
après l'élection effectivement de Trump
puisque lui-même effectivement
considérait son son nouveau combat alors
je précise il était juriste
constitutionnaliste, il est devenu un
des experts de la régulation des
réseaux. C'était c'est vraiment
quelqu'un de remarquable. Enseignant
Harvard et à Stanford. et par la suite,
il en a eu marre justement du fait de
l'évolution de cette industrie. Il
a fait une marche
et et il a fait ça et surtout il est
allé s'occupé de lutte contre la
corruption aux États-Unis, ce qui est un
vaste sujet, y compris dans le domaine
politique, c'est-à-dire dans le
financement du système politique
américain. Et donc on voit on voit là
des des trajets un peu parallèles entre
le le la pureté technologique et et la
la volonté justement humaniste d'
Schwarz et effectivement le juriste qui
devient un expert de l'internet et qui
effectivement par la suite a besoin
d'aller exprimer un autre combat. Moi,
je le regrette pour être tout à fait
sincère parce que sur le le domaine des
technologies, je crois qu'il aurait pu
continuer à nous apporter beaucoup. Mais
il est vrai que le le combat, la
noblesse du combat qu'il a aujourd'hui
contre la corruption est tout aussi
importante.
Donc pour résumer trivialement son
histoire, il a essayé de mettre le
savoir du MIT en ligne parce que en
ligne,
il trouvait que c'était un peu
scandaleux de payer 50000 dollars pour
ça alors que la connaissance doit être
libre. il s'est
il a installé de quoi copier et mettre
en ligne et ça n'a pas plu et ensuite il
a été poursuivi. Alors il était pas
poursuivi que pour ça
non
il a été poursuivi poursuivi. il a
claqué les millions de dollars qu'il
avait pour se défendre et puis après il
en a eu marre et puis voilà,
il est tombé je crois sur un procureur
qui était assez dur qui n'avait pas en
fait estimé le risque euh de fragilité
et puis surtout il a eu le sentiment euh
euh alors ça j'en parle par le biais
d'un autre ami OMIT qui m'a parlé des
derniers qui avait le sentiment d'être
un peu abandonné y compris par les gens
qui l'ont soutenu. Et en même temps euh
je comprends ce par quoi il est passé
parce qu'on a tous on a tous été des un
peu des pionniers et aujourd'hui
ce qu'on voit ce qu'on tous les jours le
c'est quand on quand on a quand on on
voit ce que l'internet devient ce que le
discours sur l'internet devient
c'est-à-dire que dans les années 95
16 quand l'internet arrive en France et
que les politiques savent pas trop mais
ceuxl souvent ont une une vision plus
juste de ce du débat aujourd'hui quand
on voit les débats sur la sur la loi
Avia sur sur la la loi sur le
renseignement sur le le pseudony c'est
qu'on revient en fait sur les mêmes
choses et c'est c'est un côté un peu
déprimant. Moi, je m'étais très impliqué
au à la loi d'Afsie. Donc la loi avant,
celle de puisqu'on avait réussi à faire
sauter la loi, elle a été revoté. Je me
suis retrouvé convoqué par Sarkozi,
enfin sa sa directrice à l'époque
Emmanuel Mignon, pour
essayer de parler de de MP3. Quand on
voit ce qui s'est passé après avec la
Dopie, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec la
on a l'impression en fait que c'est des
sujets qui reviennent en permanence et
et je vais être très honnête, parfois je
ne comprends pas pourquoi euh le débat
euh sur la haine, sur Internet, le débat
tout sur le le pseudonymat, enfin
l'anonymat qui a été apparemment qui
revient sont des sont des faux débats.
Les les les vrais débats, c'est comment
on construit des infrastructures et des
outils. cette pandémie
et donc la la pandémie de cette crise du
Covid a montré qu'en France on a un
problème d'infrastructure et d'outil.
J'ai appris par un ami que apparemment
le KNED utilise une techno américaine
qui s'appelle Blackboard qu'il est
probable que je ne sais pas que les
données sont aux États-Unis.
Si on avait des infrastructures, donc
des outils et qu'on dise aux gens
débrouillez-vous, organisez-vous, ce qui
est incroyable avec les hôpitaux, c'est
que pendant que le sommet était
complètement paralysé, les réunions de
crise ou en fait les power points et
cetera, l'hôpital a géré les choses, ils
ont géré au jour le jour. Et si on avait
des infrastructures, c'est du duodbit
des des des etils qu'on puisse donner
aux gens et de la formation euh
suffisante, on pourrait en fait laisser
les gens se débrouiller et construire
quelque chose de décentralisé. Cette
idée en fait euh pour moi, elle est très
importante, c'est qu'en fait au lieu de
faire une start-up nation, il faudrait
qu'on fasse une infrastructure nation.
c'est qu'on investisse l'argent que l'on
a à construire une infrastructure qui
soit stable, qui soit sur le long terme.
J'espère qu'on parlera un peu de slow
web après, mais pour moi, le rôle de
l'État, c'est de ralentir le temps dans
le slow maintenant.
Ah ! Alors,
si on parle du parallèle que euh la
Google et le McDonald's de la pensée,
donc il faut autre chose, il faut du
faut du bio, faut repartir sur quelque
chose. On est en fait ce que l'on mange.
Aujourd'hui, ce qu'on consomme
numériquement, c'est assez peu digeste.
C'est euh dépression, c'est euh la
dépression, c'est les teenagers.
permanent c'est c'est devenu il y avait
un article qui est sorti dans vie
atlantique qui était terrifiant quand on
voyait les ce qui ce que les les gamins
qui sont en permanence sur Instagram et
désormais sur TikTok à se comparer à une
vision euh qui n'est même pas la une
fausse vision de leurs amis cette idée
qu'on est en permanence jugé.
Il faut il faut repenser les choses. Et
donc moi ce qui ce qui me plaît avec le
le mouvement du slowfood qui est né en
89 en Italie contre l'arrivée de de
McDonald's à Rome, c'est comment on
cultive, donc comment on fait grandir
les produits, comment on les cuisine
donc et surtout la convivialité de les
manger ensemble. Moi je me rappelle ces
dîners que j'adore quand on est on dîner
avec des amis euh et on parle 3h 4h le
dîner dure toute la toute la cette
convivialité finalement elle est elle
doit se traduire aussi dans le logiciel
c'est-à-dire que les données que l'on
que l'on fait grandir il faut déjà les
minimiser
la manière dont on fait les produits et
la manière dont on les sert et
l'expérience doit être différente. Et
donc l'idée du slowb c'est il y a quatre
quatre idées. La première, c'est le fait
qu'il y a une transparence. Logiciel que
l'on a aujourd'hui n'est pas
transparent. Quand je prends Facebook et
que je like une photo, on a l'impression
que l'action que je fais, c'est liker
une photo et la personne dont j'ai liké
la photo va recevoir une notification.
Vous avez été liké par Taric. Mais la
réalité, c'est que derrière, il y a
plusieurs algorithmes, notamment le edge
rank qui va faire "Ah, telle personne,
il a like plus souvent, donc je vais
changer l'organisation. Ah, il y a
analysé la photo avec Inia, il y a un
chien he je vais lui vendre des
croquettes pour chiens. Ah tiens, il
veut il a envie d'aller en voyage, j'ai
analysé tel chat. Donc et en fait, il y
a il y a peut-être 30 40 choses qui vont
se faire avec un simple une simple
action. Cette action n'est pas visible
par l'utilisateur. Le minimum ça serait
que l'on dise un algorithme a choisi euh
l'ensemble des choses que vous voyez a
été choisie par un algorithme. Elles
sont pas là par le biais du hasard. La
deuxième chose, c'est la non
manipulation. Ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure, c'est que avec le le le design,
ce qu'on appelle les notamment les dark
patterns, c'est l'idée de d'obliger les
gens à faire certaines choses. Euh ça
c'est un vrai problème. C'est un
problème éthique, c'est un problème qui
est connu. C'est un problème d'ailleurs
qui utilise de plus en plus les les
termes. J'avais quand j'avais signé
contre le référendum, j'étais opposé
évidemment à à la vente d'aéroport de
Paris. Je me suis rendu compte que la
que l'affichage
il fallait écrire en majuscule et il
fallait utiliser l'ordre exact de sa
carte de d'identité mais c'était pas
indiqué. Quand j'ai voulu me faire
rembourser ma carte Navigo, enfin je
sais pas si quelqu'un a réussi à se
rembourser sa carte navigo. Quand j'ai
vu le système, je me suis dit en fait si
l'on veut pas qu'on fasse quelque chose
en ligne et qu'est-ce qui se passe le
jour où où il y a plus de bureau
physique pour faire les choses ? Moi ce
qui ce qui me ce qui m'énerve avec le
discours qu'on entend là, oui, il faut
mettre tout le monde sur internet. Il y
a des gens qui sont pas sur internet
parce qu'ils le veulent pas. Moi euh feu
ma maman quand elle allait euh elle
avait des problèmes de
d'envoyer un email à administration,
c'est quelque chose qui la stresse. Elle
a besoin de voir quelqu'un qui lui dit
"C'est bon, il y a un tampon, c'est
fait."
Voilà, il y a plein de gens qui
n'acceptent pas en fait cette idée que
virtuellement je je je discute avec une
autorité et que les outils dont je
dispose n'ont pas n'ont pas ça. La
troisième chose, c'est le le mode
incognito, c'est que ce dont on parlait
tout à l'heure, quand j'avais un iPod ou
un un baladeur MP3, il y avait pas un
algorithme pour me dire "Tu as écouté
cette chanson ? et j'ai envie d'écouter
une chanson débile sous la douche tous
les jours 50 fois. Je n'ai pas envie que
la plateforme le sache. Donc on doit
être capable de dire on stoppe. Et puis
la 4rième chose qui est un truc qui est
assez récent est assez simple, c'est le
droit de terminer une relation. C'est le
droit de dire je pars c'est fini. Euh
apparemment un un commun disait que
quand on veut se désabonner de Sky euh
qui l'équivalent de Canal Plus en
Angleterre, il fallait passer au
téléphone 1 heure avec un quelqu'un pour
vous dire "Oui, mais aujourd'hui, on
devrait dire au revoir et euh
et rends-moi mes données".
Efface mes données. Efface mes données
et donne-moi mes données. Mais mais cet
acte, cette action qui est assez simple,
pardon, je cette action qui est simple
semble complètement on a l'impression
d'avoir perdu. Quand quelqu'un part, on
a l'impression d'avoir perdu. Il faut
gagner, il faut gagner. Il faut prendre
le maximum à l'utilisateur. 4
Donc ça c'est la qurième chose. Il y a
ces quatre choses. C'est des conseils de
design. Mais je me dis que les
applications par exemple des
applications comme Doug Dog GO ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui nous on a j'ai une
petite plateforme qui est plutôt un side
project s'appelle Polite il y a plus de
trackur on fait on voilà c'est c'est la
plateforme telle qu'on voudrait l'avoir.
C'est tu as accès à tes données, tu fais
ton truc. Ça coûte 5 5 € mais ça
pourrait être gratuit mais mais si
c'était le
c'est pas c'est pas le modèle et si tu
veux partir tu cliques, on efface les
données et ça devrait être le modèle
standard
mais ça l'est pas parce qu'aujourd'hui
on considère que le que le modèle de la
de la monétisation de du behavioring est
plus rentable parce que ce modèle est un
modèle qui permet de prendre vite à une
personne alors que l'internet est là
pour Forever.
Non, non, non. Là-dessus, sur ça, on
peut on ne peut qu'être d'accord.
C'est-à-dire que en fait que l'apparente
enfin je vais pas revenir sur le débat
sur l'apparente gratuité de l'internet
qui effectivement s'est faite au
détriment des utilisateurs. Si on
aimerait bien que tu reviennes.
En gros, en gros il y a eu une période
où les gens se sont dit est-ce qu'on
peut installer par exemple des ce qu'on
appelle maintenant PayPal, c'est-à-dire
de faire payer des gens pour accéder à
des contenus. Et le choix instinctif de
tout être normal en situation
effectivement d'avoir à choisir, c'est
je ne paye pas. Le problème c'est que en
ne payant pas, on a laissé
progressivement ces méga ces giga bases
de données euh de profilage et et et
surtout donner lieu à un business qui
est totalement opaque, qui est
évidemment contraire à la loi européenne
sur du règlement sur les la protection
des données mais qu'on a pas voulu
analyser comme tel. Au point même, je
précise, qu'au lendemain de l'affaire
euh Cambridge Analytica, euh Marc
Zuckerberg, lui-même interrogé par la
très remarquable Cathy Castor, la
représentante de la Floride, je vous
invite à tous ceux qui ont pas vu cette
vidéo, c'est c'est un moment
d'anthologie d'anthologie et de et de
maîtrise politique du sujet comme
rarement on a pu le voir. Et bien
typiquement, il est obligé de dire "Oui,
nous allons cesser toute forme de
relation avec les data brokers parce
qu'effectivement le risque de
dissémination des données était beaucoup
trop grand." Il transpirait ce jour-là,
il transpirait et et ça on voyait
surtout que c'était une des pires
journées de sa vie et ça se sentait donc
c'était une audition non pas au Sénat
mais à la chambre des représentants et
c'était remarquable.
L'action a pris quand même 5 ou 7 %
après je crois.
Voilà. Mais le problème le problème
c'est que tant qu'on ne s'attaque pas au
cœur, c'està-dire au modèle économique
de ces sociétés, tant qu'on reste en se
lamentant de notre virginité perdue,
non, il faut dire à un moment donné,
comme l' parlementaires dans de nombreux
pays, pas uniquement en Europe, il y a
un moment où ce type de comportement
industriel devient toxique. Je pense que
vous savez, on parlait tout à l'heure de
de des contenus radicaux et de de de
Zenep Toufeki, la sociologue qui parlait
de de la radicalisation algorithmique.
Mais c'est pas compliqué aujourd'hui.
Google n'est évidemment pas complice du
djihadisme et des et des des des
contenus les plus extrêmes qu'ils
peuvent parfois leur insu avoir sur leur
plateforme. Mais il y a une forme de
convergence d'intérêt toxique.
C'est-à-dire que ce que démontre
l'ouvrage justement de TFKi, c'est que
en gros plus vous restez longtemps, plus
ça rapporte d'argent par définition à
une plateforme qui vit sur la publicité.
Et donc si il remarque que des contenus
extrêmes font que les gens restent
collés, sont addictes, par définition,
leur algorithme aura tendance à les
privilégier. Et donc on voit bien que il
y a un au-delà d'un certain seuil de
volume, de pouvoir, tout à l'heure euh
Taric parlait de de d'Eric Schmidt,
l'ancien patron de Google qui écrivait
il y a quelques années euh en gros que
que les sociétés comme la sienne avaient
vocation à remplacer les États en disant
les États sont devenus lourds, lents,
incompétents. Euh
globalement, nous aurons vocation à les
remplacer. Les gens au sein des
appareils d'état qui entendaient ça à
l'époque souriaent. Aujourd'hui, ils ne
sourit plus.
Mainant, ils sont chez Google.
Voilà. Exactement.
Ou Facebook. Faut pas oubliger que le le
créateur du Patriot euh à l'un des
co-créateurs du Patriot est maintenant
euh
euh chez chez chez Facebook. Euh
voilà. Donc par définition, on voit on
voit bien on voit bien que qu'il n'est
plus possible comme par le passé euh de
de d'envisager de façon neutre le
paysage industriel dans ces domaines. Si
on ne comprend pas que ces sociétés sont
devenues trop puissantes pour ne pas
répondre à des impératifs politiques,
c'est-à-dire en clair à une, je dirais à
une requête démocratique. Regardez ce
qui s'est passé à Toronto. Toronto c'est
un bon exemple. Vous avez une filiale de
de Google à Toronto qui s'appelait
Sidewalk Labs qui a voulu effectivement
mettre en place la ville intelligente
d'un des quartiers de Toronto. Et ben,
c'est pas compliqué. Ça ressemblait
exactement au crédit social chinois.
C'est-à-dire que quand vous regardez
dans le détail les systèmes de de prime
au comportement vertueux et au contraire
de de de non prime voir de sanction pour
des comportements qui ne seraient pas
vertueux au sens où Google l'entendait.
Au bout d'un moment, vous avez des
citoyens de Toronto qui ont dit "Nous
n'avons pas voté pour le patron de
Google, ce n'est pas à lui de diriger
nos vies." Et donc je je dirais ce qui
était vrai pour ce quartier de Toronto
doit être vrai, je dirais au minimum de
l'Union européenne voire plus.
C'est-à-dire que nous n'avons pas à
laisser des sociétés qui ne répondent
pas à l'intérêt général se prétendre.
Vous savez, vous souvenez du du slogan
de Google, "Don't do evil". Ne faites
pas de mal. À l'heure qu'il est, on peut
se poser sérieusement la question de
savoir tout le mal qu'on pu faire ces
sociétés. Facebook la première, je
dirais quasi égalité mais on ne peut pas
laisser ça. Et je pense que là là où
nous nous rejoignons avec nos angles de
vue différents sur la question, sur nos
expériences de vie, c'est que à un
moment donné ces questions deviennent
hautement politiques. Je citais Larry
Lesig tout à l'heure qui qui a créé
cette phrase devenue célèbre Codisl
qui est un monstre. D'ailleurs, c'est
vraiment
bon c'est une personne que j'ai eu grand
plaisir à faire connaître en France et
en Europe. Et ben c'est pas compliqué.
Euh la phrase suivante, c'est c'était
lors d'un débat qu'on avait eu
d'ailleurs avec lui à Science Po à
l'époque, c'était architecture is
politics. C'est-à-dire que
l'architecture du code, un peu comme
l'avait dit Raymond dans son ouvrage
Éric Raymond cathédrale bazar, c'est que
le code devient porteur de de de valeur
politique. Si nous ne si
si on nudite pas le code, on est coincé.
Exactement. Ça c'est la le propos d'un
autre grand spécialiste de ces
questions, Franck Pasqual qui a écrit
effectivement sur le la Black Box
Society, la société boîte noire qu'il
nous faut auditer le code, qu'il ne faut
pas laisser des gens qui ont une vision
purement économique. Tout à l'heure
parler des deux types d'algorithmes qui
sont l'un censé augmenter le le
l'interaction et l'autre censé la
contrôler. On voit bien que la chose est
totalement biaisée et que la main gauche
qui va récupérer de la puissance
marketing ne sera jamais handicapée par
la main droite. C'est ce que montre
Zuckerberg tous les jours dans son
incapacité à réformer. Je dirais ne
serait-ce que les propos de haine sur la
plateforme mais on pourrait le dire bien
au-delà sur la publicité politique. Ce
qu'a fait Jacques Dorset sur Twitter.
Facebook s'y oppose avec la dernière des
énergies et sauf à y être contraint. Et
on a vu que même Unilever, même
Coca-Cola, même les grandes marques
américaines qui se sont coalisées, qui
ont envisagé un boycotte de la
plateforme n'arrivent pas à faire plier
Facebook. Je pense qu'à un moment donné
seul l'antitrust, alors je je précise,
prenez vos vos carnets, vos crayons. Je
crois que c'est le 27 juillet qu'il y a
la première audition de tous les patrons
de de des GAFA euh par rapport à
l'antitrust américain. On va voir
effectivement où la chose mène. Mais on
se rend compte que même aux États-Unis,
la puissance cumulée, la puissance
politique et économique cumulée de ces
plateformes devient intolérable. Ce qui
avait mené en d'autres temps la la
fragmentation de sociétés comme ATT donc
à l'époque ou historiquement Exon avec
la standard de H. Typiquement, je pense
qu'on est à un moment titre.
Pour ça Google a a pris les devant, non
? Oui,
avec alphabet. Tarik Hugo.
Oui. Non, j'avais de deux petits points.
Le premier, quand on dit il faut réguler
les algorithmes, il faut les auditer.
Encore faut-il les comprendre ?
Oui. Oui.
Euh pas du tout évident. Et euh moi j'ai
une théorie ce que j'appelle les
suprémacistes numériques. Donc il y a
c'est une vision politique hein qui se
traduit maintenant par ce qu'on appelle
le néoféodalisme. C'est une c'est la
vision un peu à la mode dans la Silicone
Vallée, c'est de dire qu'on revient au
temps des seigneurs. Le Seigneur est
tout-puissant, il lève la dîme mais il
protège aussi. Euh donc ça face à
évidemment face à l'état à l'État ntion.
Euh donc il y a cette idée que le on
revient au tout départ ce combat entre
les gens qui voulaient la vision
humaniste d'augmenter les compétences
humaines et de les remplacer.
Pour ces gens-là, le monde est une
équation mathématique qu'il faut
optimiser. Et quand on optimise la
démocratie, à la fin, on arrive à un
modèle ben dont on parlait tout à
l'heure, soit ce qui a été fait à
Toronto, soit ce qui se fait
quotidiennement en Chine. Donc ça c'est
un premier point. Alors sur la question
des
de casser les big tech, moi je j'ai une
vision un peu différente
parce que je crois qu'aujourd'hui déjà
un, je pense que ça va pas se faire
parce que les États-Unis veulent
conserver des puissances très
importantes mais surtout je crois que
l'ensemble de ces sociétés se sont
préparés à être cassé. Par exemple, je
donne un exemple tout bête. Si demain
Amazon Web Service est séparé d'Amazon,
ça devient instantanément la 10e dans le
top 10 des boîtes les plus profitables.
Ce qui s'est passé pendant longtemps,
c'est que le les profits qui étaient
faits par Amazon Web Services, on on
l'oublie, mais Amazon Web Servic est né
du fait que Amazon avait des pics de
connexion énormes pendant des moments
très précis, Black Friday et autres, et
que le reste du temps, ils avaient de la
puissance massive. Donc, ils ont décidé
de la mettre à disposition des autres,
notamment leur concurrent Netflix entre
autres.
Et et donc euh cette pendant longtemps
les profits d'Amazon puisque c'est une
de web service que les gens payent en
fait pour transférer leur informatique
sur le cloud donc c'est extrêmement
profitable servait à financer une chose
chez chez Amazon, c'est l'oxygène du
e-commerce, c'est les frais de
livraison. On s'est retrouvé plusieurs
fois avec des des Black Friday, donc des
les fameux les fameux jours de solde où
90 % donc le jour de l'année où vous
vendez le plus de produits, 90 % des
frais de livraison sont offerts parce
que si Amazon les offre, tous les autres
sont obligés de le faire et tous les
autres tirent la langue. Et là, ce qui
se passe maintenant avec Amazon, c'est
qu'ils ont une nouvelle entité qui fait
de la publicité, qui est désormais
numéro 3 derrière Facebook et Google aux
États-Unis, qui a suffisamment
maintenant d'argent pour alimenter euh
cette stratégie d'Amazon. Et donc, si on
sépare Amazon Web Services, euh, elle va
devenir une société très profitable. Euh
pour Facebook, c'est un peu plus un peu
plus difficile mais ils ont déjà
commencé à réfléchir en interne à cette
question de séparer les entités euh en
tant que pour Google, ça sera ça serait
évident de séparer Android du moteur de
recherche, mais Alphabet d'une certaine
manière, ça a été la façon de préparer
ça. La société qui est plutôt mal en
point face à ça, c'est Apple.
C'est-à-dire que dans 5 ans quand ils
auront une entité de service qui qui
gagnera suffisamment d'argent pour
séparer le hardware parce que Apple est
avant tout une société de hardware. Le
logiciel est était
plus maintenant
était avant avant tout. Il commence à
l'être. D'ailleurs, on le voit
maintenant, ils font des des téléphones
des services constituent part important
de leur revenu. Aujourd'hui,
ce qui est intéressant, c'est
qu'aujourd'hui, ils font des téléphones
pas chers là nouveau nouveau entré de
gamme parce qu' ils vont passer dans le
service. Alors le problème c'est que
ça c'est un une chose sur laquelle la
Commission européenne aurait dû
travailler depuis des années. Quand on
vend un produit sur l'App Store, quand
vous êtes une boîte et vous faites 30 %
de marge, c'est pas mal mais dans le
monde d'Apple, les 30 % vont à Apple et
vous vous débrouillez avec le reste. Et
on a laissé ça pendant 10 ans. On a fêté
là les 10 ans de l' de l'App Store
pareil avec Google. On a donc laissé en
fait quasiment un holdup des bandits de
grand chemin qui ont ponné cet argent et
Apple et la société à mon avis dans
cette idée où on séparerait qui n'est
pas encore prête. Dans 5 ans, elle le
sera mais aujourd'hui elle elle l'est
pas. Mais moi, je ne crois pas qu'aux
États-Unis quiconque osera toucher à ces
à ces sociétés. C'est dommage parce que
le vrai sujet c'est qu'on devrait le
faire non pas parce qu'on est
anticapitaliste, mais parce qu'on est
justement capitaliste et qu'il faut
laisser de nouvelles société émerger. Et
aujourd'hui, c'est c'est impossible.
Vous ne pouvez rien faire.
Ben, je dirais, on pensait la même chose
justement par rapport au telco, par
rapport au télécom et on avait un un
monopole sur les sur les communications
longue distance qui était tel
qu'effectivement à un moment donné la
question s'est posée. Je rappelle que
les lois antitrust portent le nom
d'antitrust aux États-Unis, Sherman Act
pour les plus juristes d'entre vous,
Antitrust parce que la Sandra Dog
n'était pas une société, c'était un
trust. Donc en gros ce que j'essaie de
dire c'est que aujourd'hui faire des
lois spécifiques pour Google, pour
Facebook est une chose possible. Est-ce
qu'on le fera à horizon prévisible court
? Non. Mais il faut être très clair
aujourd'hui. La la capacité
d'étouffement, tout à l'heure, il était
question de l'oxygène par rapport à tel
ou tel secteur d'activité. La capacité
d'étouffement de ces sociétés par
rapport effectivement à leur écosystème
est devenue telle que tout l'écosystème
industriel se rend compte qu'il doit
payer. Tout à l'heure, on parlait d'une
diîme, d'une taxe. En gros, euh pour
exister aujourd'hui tant commercialement
que en terme marketing, on doit payer la
taxe à des grands acteurs qui
effectivement vous permettent d'exister.
demander à la presse. On on nous sommes
tous euh je dirais euh mais consternés
la quoi
la presse qui en particulier la presse
locale qui a connu une décrue dramatique
dans tous les pays euh occidentaux.
Typiquement, je veux dire à un moment
donné tous les tous les acteurs de la
presse magazine en France par exemple
vous disent si on se si on devait
rentrer en conflit avec Google sur
Google News ou avec Facebook, c'est 40 %
de notre chiffre d'affaires qui s'en va.
de notre trafic et de notre capacité de
valorisation. Donc par définition, c'est
évident que la chose est dangereuse,
mais à un moment donné euh ce rapport de
féodalité, rappelons rappelons pourquoi
la la loi titreuse a été créée, c'était
pour éviter que que de de se plier
devant de nouveaux féodux. Euh euh euh
ceux qui l'avaient créé disaient "Nous
avons effectivement réussi à nous sortir
de l'emprise des griffes d'un d'un roi.
Ce n'est pas pour tomber sous l'emprise
de quelques barons industriel euh que ce
soit aujourd'hui." Donc vous voyez cette
logique-là, à un moment donné
l'écosystème euh est on est je dirais au
début de la crise globale par rapport à
ça. Est-ce qu'elle aboutira ? Si si
demain Ellisabeth Warren devait être
patronne du département du commerce ou
pire encore pour pour ces sociétés du
département de la justice là tout tous
les tous les Paris serait ouvert. Mais
je dirais que le le l'hyperconcentration
à laquelle on a assisté elle devient
toxique globalement pour l'économie et y
compris pour l'économie américaine.
Certes, je suis d'accord avec Taric, le
gouvernement américain souhaite
conserver ses champions, mais est-ce que
tous les autres accepteront durablement
la taxe des 30 % pour les applications
ou effectivement la taxe publicitaire
sur l'ensemble de de leurs activités ?
Ça c'est beaucoup moins évident, y
compris même à l'intérieur des
États-Unis.
Tar, tu veux rajouter juste un mot ?
Juste un mot. Je pense qu'on a un
problème de timing, c'est que tout ça
était vrai avant la crise de Covid et on
se trouve dans une situation qui est un
peu compliquée, c'est que le Covid a
accéléré la transition numérique de 5
ans, 10 ans peut-être, il y a des choses
qu'on faisait pas avant qu'on fait
et que Biden, s'il était élu
h
a un autre problème, c'est qu'il va
avoir 40 millions de chemurs. il est
dans un état qui est en déliescence
totale, donc il aura d'autres problèmes
et je pense que pour les 4 ans voire
possiblement les 8 ans qui viennent, ces
gens n'auront pas n'auront pas la
capacité de faire tout ce qui doit être
fait qui je pense
et et effectivement aurait dû être fait.
Donc ça pose la question de ce que
l'Europe peut faire, ce que l'Europe
veut faire,
doit faire,
ce que l'Europe devrait faire, doit
faire aussi. Mais et là, c'est vrai
qu'on a une on a un problème de
lisibilité parce que ces questions sont
pas sont pas sont pas sans être sans
être particulièrement
sévère par rapport à nos voisins
britanniques. le départ des Britanniques
de l'Union s'il devait se réaliser
double peine
pardon
non le départ serait serait peut-être
une chance sur les questions de
régulation parce que on parlait tout à
l'heure de Small Business Act qui ont
été particulièrement nocifs par rapport
à cette notion c'était justement les
Britanniques sur effectivement la
régulation du marché les actions
antitrust je pense qu'on pourrait
effectivement aller plus vite désormais
je crois qu' il y a une une opportunité
par rapport à ça qui méritera d'être
joué voyez c'est l'ancien négociateur UR
européen qui a eu l'occasion de beaucoup
œuvrer et de voir les difficultés à de
se coordonner à 27 à l'époque. Je crois
que sincèrement on est face à un
changement et et l'Europe se rend compte
que la naïveté qui a été la sienne par
rapport aux deux blocs chinois et
américains, elle devient autement.
C'était de la naïveté ou non ? parce que
ça me paraît quand même un peu qu' a eu
des gens qui
attendez que que moi je me souviens des
propos de Michel Rard qui disait je n'ai
jamais vu
avant juste avant
voilà qui il y a quelques années qui
disaient je n'ai jamais vu un lobbying
aussi violent que sur les questions de
data Bruxelles. Donc par définition qui
est qui est sur les les sujets que nous
évoquons des des tentations d'influence,
c'est évident mais qui est parmi ceux
qui ne sont pas manipulés qu'il y ait
effectivement une forme de passivité une
forme de de résignation sur le mode de
toute manière on peut pas faire sans
eux. Quelqu'un a fait d'ailleurs
récemment, je crois que c'est dans le
journal du Net, une typologie de de des
des gens qui étaient pour ou contre la
souveraineté numérique. Et on voyait les
opportunistes, les militants. Alors, moi
j'étais bien sûr dans le côté militant,
mais on voyait effectivement les types
de discours que ça gênéit aujourd'hui. À
la différence d'il y a 5 ans quand on
avait créé l'institut, il y a 5 ans, on
nous disait l'Institut de la
souveraineté numérique. On nous disait
"Mais qu'est-ce que c'est la
souveraineté numérique ? C'était un
signe tank privé. Moi, je sortais de mes
fonctions de délégué interministériel."
Donc c'était pas du tout une structure
publique et donc on s'est regroupé avec
quelques-uns donc Taric nous a rejoint
dans notre conseil scientifique
typiquement pour réfléchir à ces
questions sur les questions de relation
internationale par rapport effectivement
au numérique et par rapport en
particulier au numérique européen. Euh
et ben il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui tout
le monde parle de souveraineté numérique
pas simplement Syerview. Tout le monde
parle de souveraineté numérique.
Ça fait longtemps qu'on en parle. Je
sais, je sais bien, je sais que c'est un
sujet que vous avez abordé avec de
nombreuses avec de nombreuses
personnalités. Et bien, typiquement
aujourd'hui, la question c'est comment
se détermine-t-on par rapport à ce sujet
? Si on se détermine mollement, c'est
quelque part on était contre.
Aujourd'hui, seules des solutions non
pas radicales mais je dirais politiques,
doivent être envisagées.
Solution politique dans la même phrase
et ben malheureusement il y a encore des
gens pour y croire.
Il y a des gens encore pour y croire.
Il faut rajouter courage et là c'est
c'est si elle tire c'est gagnants là.
Courage, politique, solution.
Je sens je sens je sens désabusé. Non
non non. Réaliste. Pragmatique
pragmatique. L'observation montre que
des tout à l'heure Tar parlait de la
crise Covid. La crise Covid a été un
accélérateur sur tous les plans.
Peut-être même sera-t-elle
l'accélérateur du déclin voire de
l'expulsion du champ politique d'un
certain Donald Trump si on en croit les
sondages ce que ce que nous verrons
encore dans quelques temps. Mais en tout
cas je dirais que politiquement
ou pas
Ouais. À voir, à voir. Ce que ce que
l'on voit c'est que globalement
le le l'inaction sera considérée comme
une faute politique dans ce domaine dans
pas très longtemps, là où auparavant
elle était considérée comme bénige.
C'est-à-dire que moi j'ai connu des
ministres à qui on disait "Ne vous
affiche surtout pas sur les
technologies, vous allez y perdre en
crédibilité." Je citerai pas le nom des
ministres mais leur cabinet leur disait
ça à qui on disait "Az
le nom du chef de cabinet Non, je ne
dirai pas
mais typiquement typiquement on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui ces questions,
regardez aujourd'hui il est question de
quoi taxe gafa avec toutes les
difficultés qu'il y aura à la mettre en
œuvre évidemment mais il est question
tout d'un coup on reparle de champions
européens le le récent discours de
politique générale c'était 40 milliards
pour l'industrie. On verra ce qu'il en
sera fait.
Comment il s'appelait le débuté là ? Bon
euh qui avait fait un rapport sur les
serveurs chinois que c'était très très
grave que machin mais il parlait pas du
tout des serveurs américains. Vous vous
rappelez pas de ce mec-là ?
Non.
Passons.
Question internet. J'ai peut-être loupé
des morceaux mais en parlant
d'infrastructure quid deh. C'est
français non ?
Oui.
Ils sont costauds point d'interrogation.
Oui. Alors attendez, je vais je vais je
vais prendre là-dessus et je pense que
Tottaric pourrait conclure. Lorsque
notre secrétaire d'État au numérique
disait devant la représentation
nationale Joui,
pardon,
j'ai pas compris. Le Cédico.
Cédrico
oui il y a quelques semaines disait
"Nous avons construit le data hub, il
n'y avait pas de solution européenne
voir française pour le faire."
Or je vais vous dire
et je veux travailler chez Microsoft le
mois prochain
ça. Chacun à chacun de conclure. Non.
Fondamentalement d'abord un quand on
voit un projet d'une importance
stratégique telle et qu'on se dit on ne
peut le confier qu'un américain comme le
disait un certain président de la
République française il y a quelques
années, il est urgent d'attendre.
C'estàd que était-il nécessaire de
commencer ? Je précise que c'était bien
avant le Covid he pour ceux qui se
poseraient la question. Le SD, on en
parle maintenant en période Covid mais
il a été décidé il y a plus d'un an. Et
donc par définition
était-il prudent d'établir la maquette,
le POC comme on dit dans ces domaines,
le proof of concept, la maquette avec
Microsoft au point que Microsoft bien
sûr ajoute des briques de fonctionnalité
qui font qu'au final ils sont quasiment
les seuls à pouvoir répondre. La réponse
c'est non. Là, moi j'ai parlé dans une
dans une tribune sur ce sujet au point
j'ai parlé de paresse intellectuelle
parce que pour avoir dirigé des projets
d'administration centrale, par
définition, on pouvait faire autrement.
On a été au plus vite et malheureusement
sans se rendre compte des effets de bord
des risques que ça faisait courir aux
données des Français et en particulier à
leurs données les plus stratégiques que
sont les données de santé. Donc par
définition, je dirais que là-dessus,
mais là je vais prendre le pouvoir le le
point de vue Gill Babinet. Oui,
il y a les données optin et il y a donné
optout. Non
mais non, dans ces domaines. Non
non, d'abord euh attendez
Tar pourquoi tu te mars ? Non non mais
euh non mais je en fait j'ai fait il y a
tu
utilise
pardon non mais j'ai fait un j'avais
fait un rapport qui a servi de
Calarmoire à à l'époque de de Fleur
Pèlerin justement sur ces questions et
et j'avais une une question une réponse
assez simple c'est dès qu'on met des
gens qui savent de quoi ils parlent donc
des gens qui sont techniques dans les
conversations,
soudain les choses se se passent mieux.
J'aimerais toujours un de mes anciens
associés qui avait monté une web agency,
un de ses commerciaux lui avait avait
vendu des pages web rondes
et il a dû lui expliquer que c'était pas
possible. Et et en fait, on a on a un on
a un vrai problème, c'est qu'on a des
talents exceptionnels
et on a beaucoup de sculpteurs de fumée.
Et on a surtout et je je tiens à je veux
juste préciser quand on monte des des
plateformes parce que tu tu vous parliez
de d'OVH euh OVH c'est ils sont assez
imbattables sur la machine nue. Il faut
tout faire soi-même. Il faut
l'installer, mettre l'OS, les
plateformes. On a une des gens qu'on
appelle des DevOps ou des avant ça des
administrateurs système. Enfin donc il y
a des gens dont le métier c'est de
préparer, de déployer, de s'organiser.
Alors quand j'étais ancienne vie,
j'avais travaillé chez Infony faire de
l'internet. J'avais un jeune lyonnais,
enfin jeune Lyonnais était un peu plus
âgé que moi mais il était quand même
jeune à l'époque. Maintenant c'est lui
qui déploie pour tout Google et
s'appelle Eric Dumazé. un type
exceptionnel qui patchait Linux en
assembleur. Enfin, c'était vraiment un
un type des gens comme lui, il y en a il
y en a pas beaucoup mais des gens de
très bon niveau d'Op, il y en a plein.
Donc c'est des gens qui sont capables,
vous leur dites voilà, on va acheter, on
va mettre 50 machines. Ce qui est
fascinant, c'est qu'une partie des
outils qu'on utilise dans le F data mais
aussi dans l'intelligence artificielle
notamment des technos comme Pych It
Learn ou Jupiter Notebook ont été
développé en France. Le rapport de
Cédric Vilani sur l'IA qui est fait avec
un le directeur de thèse ne mentionne
même pas les technos.
Après elles sont il y a un problème en
ce moment avec le logiciel libre et les
grandes plateformes parce que les
grandes plateformes utilisent les
logiciels libres et ne commitent pas les
sources parce que maintenant en fait ils
ne font pas de distribution.
Mais on pourrait en fait reprendre
d'ailleurs, j'ai suite à à l'histoire de
de Cédrico, moi ça m'avait choqué que
indépendamment c'est comme si un
ministre de l'agriculture arrive et dit
le bœf le bœuf argentin c'est quand même
meilleur que le que le bœuf français. il
resterait pas très longtemps à
voilà et donc ça m'avait choqué mais ce
qui est fascinant dans dans cette
histoire c'est quand on a j'ai discuté
avec Octave donc toute transparence
Octave Clabal le fondateur de je dit
mais ce que je comprenais pas en fait et
il me dit mais nous on n' jamais eu de
véritable
c des charges ou en tout cas
ce que je sais des ingénieurs français
que j'ai vu dans toutes les boîtes je
pense à mais en a plein d'autres outcal
il y a quand on leur dit voilà ce qu'on
voudrait avoir on va le construire.
On construit euh quand on développe une
boîte puisque là on a un peu joué à la
start-up, on invente quelque chose de
nouveau. C'est vrai que la start-up
nation a plutôt eu comme directive de
copier les les concepts américains et de
les franciser comme on le faisait à
l'époque avec les les gens de la
chanson. on prenait des des de la de la
chanson française, c'était la version
américaine du rock et de de Elvis
Presley. On a fait un peu la même chose
avec les start-ups, mais on construit et
donc pour ça, on dit quelle va être
l'architecture, quels sont les outils
qu'on va utiliser et pour et pour ça, il
faut amener dans la conversation des
gens qui en général dans les
administrations sont au troisème
sous-sol, des gens qu'on méprise. On par
que moi ce qui m'a toujours fasciné,
qu'on sous paye, mais ce qui m'a
toujours fasciné, c'est que les gens
sont bons. l'ancien l'ancien directeur
système du ministère de l'intérieur ou
de Ber je crois qu' est allé après à
Général Motors ce type était
brillantissime il était en plus respecté
il y a eu des choses qui ont été faites
à la gendarmerie nationale logiciel
libre end to end donc les gens sont là
mais comment se fait-il que ces gens ne
sont jamais dans les conversations et
qu'à la fin on se retrouve avec des gens
qui
on a tous la réponse autour de cette
table ici on le sait alors dites-le
je te vois sourire avec un petit sourire
en co une petite faussette
attendez On le sait tous.
On le sait tous.
On va le dire, on va le dire autrement.
Pour avoir renseigné dans certaines
grandes écoles de ce de ces domaines,
euh je vous raconte l'anecdote. Euh j'ai
créé les premiers enseignements à Lena
sur internet et administration
électronique. 98 quand même.
Ah non, moi c'était c'était un one shot.
C'était un one shot. Mais c'est pas
compliqué. À l'époque, je leur disais
bientôt vous serez jugé, noté sur ce que
vous faites sur internet. éclat dans la
salle.
Bah, il s'est trouvé que maintenant
personne ne rirait. Personne ne rirait.
Mais pour reprendre le propos, il est
évident que les technologies ont pendant
très longtemps pour des littéraires que
je connais bien parce que j'en ai
beaucoup fréquenté, des juristes, des
littéraires, les technologies c'était du
contingent, c'était des choses
secondaires. La décision politique
c'était autre chose que de s'occuper de
machines, de technologies et cetera. Et
ben non. Et c'est pour ça que quand on
voit des juristes d'un tel talent
puisque tout à l'heure on parlait de les
SIG de venir à ce point compétent alors
qui n'a je le précise à aucun moment
étudier les technologies de façon
universitaire c'est vraiment un
autodidacte des technologies complet lui
céit un juriste constitutionnaliste
voyez donc il était pas du tout
là-dedans et ben c'est et un philosophe
oui je précise aussi une formation de
philosophe mais c'est pas compliqué je
veux dire on a eu des gens qui ont été
curieux et qui n'ont pas méprisé ces
sujets notre problème c'est que trop
souvent on a dit d'un côté il y a
l'ingénieur qui va s'occuper de faire en
sorte que le courant fonctionne dans la
maison et de l'autre côté, il y a le
politique qui va s'occuper des textes
juridiques, des textes législatifs et
effectivement de la régulation de tout
ça.
Je dirais que là-dessus, alors même
qu'on avait parmi les meilleurs
ingénieurs du monde, puisque tout à
l'heure on parlait des grandes époques
de la décision de politique industrielle
française, on avait des ingénieurs de
talent avec des politiques qui les
comprenaient et qui savaient leur donner
les moyens qu'il fallait. Et je
rappellerai que la que la les les
projets atomiques et autres sont nés
avant même le général de Gaulle. déjà la
4e République, il y avait déjà
effectivement euh avant avant ce que
l'on a pensé être uniquement le la
période clé ou charnière, il y avait
déjà une volonté dans ces domaines.
Aujourd'hui, je dirais malgré toutes les
suspicions qu'on peut avoir, moi je
dirais il y a une forme de de je dirais
de de vision résignée de ce futur en
disant de toute manière on a loupé la
marche. Je l'ai souvent entendu à Ber me
dirent sur internet c'est trop tard. Et
bien je dirais les les scandales
auxquels on a assisté à répétition
Snowden, Cambridge Analytica et Consort
nous donne entre guillemets une
possibilité de revenir dans le jeu. Soit
nous le prenons, nous la prenons cette
possibilité, soit nous laissons
la chose dérivée comme elle a dérivé ces
15 ou 20 dernières années.
Tombé dans le misérabilisme de
l'impuissance.
Question d'internet, doit-on se méfier
de la 5G et de l'arrivée massive de
Huawei dans le monde notamment en Europe
? Ben ce qui est fascinant, alors la 5G,
on pourrait dire beaucoup de choses,
hein.
Moi, je trouve que l'ARCEP a été assez
mauvaise sur la gestion de la partie
onde et 5G. Enfin bon, il y a
euh donc je vais pas parler de ça, mais
il y a il y a il y a plusieurs choses
sur la 5. J'ai la première, c'est que
euh on change un peu de paradigme. C'est
que jusqu'à maintenant, on avait des
technos qui étaient du haut débit. Donc
pour beaucoup de gens, la 5G c'est
encore plus de débit. D'ailleurs, quand
on écoute le le nouveau maire de
Grenoble d'expliquer que 5G ça sert à si
j'ai bien compris à tél dans l'ascenseur
dans l'ascenseur parce que il a il a dû
remarquer que la 3G ou la 4G marchait
pas très bien dans l'ascenseur.
Il y a moins de caméra dans les
ascenseurs
mais alors d'une certaine manière je
comprends ce qu'il dit et j'ai si j'ai
juste un un instant pour l'expliquer. Je
pense que une grande partie des gens ont
l'impression que le monde va trop vite
que c'est on est dans une forme de
barrière d'abstraction. C'est que le
monde est devenu abstrait, on comprend
plus rien. Et pour beaucoup de gens,
alors moi je pensais pendant longtemps
que l'IA, l'IA c'est le mot clé pour
dire licenciement. On va on va mettre de
l'IA dans une dans une société, ça veut
dire on va remplacer les gens.
Euh je pensais que Len allait être le
mauvais élève, on allait être contre
l'IA, mais a priori docteur Laurent
Alexandre a fait son travail et les gens
continuent à penser que c'est une force
de bien. Euh et finalement, c'est la 5G
qui a pris
euh cette idée que le monde va trop
vite. Alors derrière la 5G, il y a un
problème, c'est qu'on on a des technos
par exemple d'une boîte comme à Maris
soft qui a été fait par Fabrice Bellard.
que alors quand j'ai fait l'émission
avec Flor Pellerin, je me suis dit il
faut que je donne au moins quelques noms
et puis je me dis tiens je vais en
donner une centaine. Alors après je me
suis un peu fait engueuler parce que tu
aurais pu mettre un tel mais j'ai mis
100 personnes qui ont participé à des
choses vraiment importantes. Et ce type
ben là si on peut regarder la vidéo dans
Chrome c'est grâce à lui. Il a fait QMU
et il a en train de révolutionner
il a fait en fait on peut prendre un PC
à 400 € et on le transforme en bog
donc ça coûte rien. on n'est pas obligé
d'acheter. Lui a carrément outmarté
Huawei. Une des raisons pour lesquelles
on achète Huawei, c'est que ça coûte pas
cher. Il y a aussi le fait qu'ils ont
été rapidement, ils ont commencé
rapidement à à la déployer en Chine.
Donc ça a été un peu plus vite. Et nous,
on a on a un sujet, c'est qu'on n'est
même pas sûr que les opérateurs ont
l'argent parce qu'on sait même pas
combien vont coûter les licences. Donc,
on est vraiment en retard. Euh il y a un
problème évidemment de de de
souveraineté puisque là on met carrément
dans le cœur de réseau des boîtes
noires. On a aussi déjà des boîtes
noires. On est censé depuis la loi sur
le renseignement avoir des boîtes noires
mais elles sont censées être de
fabrication française si j'ai compris.
Là on passe sur
on passe sur quelque chose de de de plus
inquiétant.
des boîtes noires piloté de la Chine.
Hm hm.
Mais surtout euh
alors à une époque où la technologie
était importante notamment chez France
Télécom. Alors j'ai passé ma jeunesse à
à me fiche d' parce qu'on faisait du
fracking, on s'amusait à détourner les
lignes de téléphone. Mais France Télécom
obsédé par la qualité de service. C'est
qu'à une époque
euh on a on a pas forcément on était pas
forcément d'accord avec l'architecture
très centralisatrice du Militel et de la
numériste mais c'était la qualité de
service c'est que le truc marchait.
Maintenant, on est passé à un système où
on est au milieu du Marais et on a deux
barres, ça marche pas. Alors quand vous
êtes au Japon, vous êtes dans un club au
- 5 et vous avez 5 barres, c'est pareil
en Allemagne. Donc on a déjà perdu cette
qualité de service. Et moi ce qui
m'inquiète, c'est que les réseaux c'est
un peu devenu Frankenstein. On met un
peu de on met un peu de Huawei, on met
un peu de de d'icson, on met on sait
plus du tout comment construire les
réseaux parce qu'on ne on a encore une
fois dans les grands groupes. Alors, je
mets de côté Xavier Niel qui est qui
connaît bien le sujet, donc je le mets à
part. Euh on n plus véritablement encore
de techniciens dans les mainant vous
avez que des marketeurs ou des
politiciens de professionnels. Et donc
quand il s'agit de réfléchir à comment
on va architecturer et ça il faut le
faire 10 ans avant d'implémenter. C'est
vrai aussi chez Renault euh BMW a un
système de voiture automatique. Renault
on va passer chez Google. Donc ça veut
dire que 10 ans avant il y a des gens
qui auraient dû réfléchir à ça, qui
auraient dû aller voir l'écosystème,
voir ce qu'on peut faire. Faut pas
oublier que Renault et Pogot ont inventé
la CAO, donc la 3D en fait telle qu'on
existe. Ça a été inventé les courbes de
bazier, toute la base de la CAO a été
inventé chez Peugeot et aussi chez
Renault mais
et sauciste
euh mais là je parle dans les années 60.
on a des gens qui étaient visionnaires
et là maintenant des gens qui n'ont plus
le donc on a on a effectivement ce
problème. Donc juste pour terminer sur
la 5G euh le problème de la 5G c'est
qu'on pourrait faire des technos
beaucoup moins chers et on pourrait
aussi régler le problème des zones
blanches en les installant un peu
partout mais pour ça il faut revenir sur
un un un point important qui est la
décentralisation. Si on laissait les
gens reprendre le contrôle du réseau, on
aurait du réseau partout. Le fait qu'on
laisse maintenant un petit nombre
d'opérateurs qui ont de moins en moins
d'argent euh qui savent de moins en
moins comment ça fonctionne, je mets
encore de côté euh Xav Xavier euh pose
un problème et on a en France dans une
situation un peu unique, c'est que
partout il y aura des expérimentations
5G et en France pour l'instant on est
très en retard. Bernard ça mèche.
Alors
disons que qu'il y a un risque par
rapport à Huawei sans sans rentrer dans
des scénarios conspis comme on dit.
C'est évident. De l'autre côté je
rappellerai la déclaration d'un certain
William Bar donc le ministre de la
justice de Trump qui a dit "Nous ne
faisons pas le poids par rapport
effectivement à ces technologies 5G.
Nous avons vocation à prendre des
participations majoritaires dans les
deux sociétés européennes un peu
consistantes sur le sujet. C'estàd Nokia
Eriksson.
Donc en gros, nous apparaissons non
seulement comme le marché mais comme la
proie que l'on vient dépesser.
Donc savoir que d'un côté on a le risque
chinois et que de l'autre côté notre
allié historique ne nous voit que comme
une proie qu'il doit dépesser.
Attends, attends, l'allié historique,
j'ai pas compris là.
Je vais pas revenir.
Les débouchés, les débouchés de marché
historique. C'est ça.
Peut-être, peut-être, peut-être aussi
des jeunes gens qui meurent meurent sur
les plages normandes. Peut-être. 300000,
c'est ça 300000.
Je ne saurais dire. D'accord.
Je saurais dire. Mais ce que je veux
dire, c'est que nous Obama avait avait
eu l'occasion de dire "On est venu deux
fois face à des périls imminents pour
vous français européens et quelqu'un
avait répondu "Oui, mais vous avez aidé
avec un certain la faillette à acquérir
acquérir votre liberté face au roi
il oublie souvent il oublie souvent si
on avait pas été là il serait encore
colonie américain anglais
anglaise anglais la faillette
et je vous coupe que dire de la visite
de Larry Flint patron de Black Block à
Black Rock à l'Élysée
Rien de particulier. Moi, j'ai pas de
Moi, j'ai pas d'info, mais de fait
voilà. Alors, c'est intéressant d'un
point de vue logiciel, euh Black Rock
fait partie de ces sociétés qui ont
développé un savoir-faire sur
l'évaluation du risque qui parfois ont
pu être utilisé, y compris même au sein
des gouvernements. Donc, c'est vrai que
on a, je dirais, une interpénétration.
On a on a beaucoup parlé pour
l'administration Google Obama, vous
voyez, d'une love story entre Obama et
Google. Euh là, on voit effectivement
que il y a il y a une porosité, y
compris en période de risque qui
effectivement est une chose qui peut
poser problème.
Vous chiffrez avec quoi ?
Chiffrg
?
Je sais pas.
Non, pour les pour mes communications,
ben je suis embêté parce que j'ai
beaucoup signal et je commence à à ça
m'embête un peu déjà parce que l'un des
cfondateurs est un les deux d'ailleurs
de de WhatsApp sont des Trumpiens de de
la de la à fond, mais je je suis un peu
gêné. Euh voilà, c'est euh sinon de
toute façon rappeler que quand quelqu'un
ha le téléphone quel que soit le
logiciel,
on est
voilà, on est coincé. Donc
non, il y a il y a un vrai problème, on
parlait tout à l'heure de je voudrais
pas revenir systématiquement sur
l'antitrust mais qui a deux plateformes
qui trustent à elles seulent 95 98 % du
marché donc iOS et Android. C'est c'est
en soi et que ces deux plateformes
soient américaines, c'est en soi
effectivement un risque une exposition
au risque maximum.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Vous allez nous conseiller trois livres
chacun.
Bernard ?
Bah je je vais revenir sur
Shoshanazubov, le capitalisme de
surveillance remarquable.
Shoshanazubov
extraordinaire. Je précise effectivement
normalement en octobre, je crois qu'il
devrait être traduit en français. C'est
un gros pavé mais ça mérite vraiment.
Euh bon historique puisque j'ai cité les
SIGS tous les SIGs méritent d'être
cités. Là encore un livre que j'ai
souhaité faire traduire et qu'à l'époque
tous les éditeurs de la place de Paris
m'ont dit magnifique livre mais vous
n'aurez que 300 lecteurs maximum si on
le fait traduire c'est son premier
c'est-à-dire code et autre loi du
cyberespace qui est reste d'actualité.
Il a même fait une version élaborée en
collectif qui s'appelait code 2.0 qui
est assez remarquable. Je vous ai parlé
du Blackbox Society de de Franck Pasqual
qui est vraim vraiment utile. Là aussi,
Mariana Matzukato, l'état entrepreneur
entrepreneurial state pour revenir sur
sur le la phrase, je n'ose revenir sur
la phrase d'un certain George Bush
Junior qui avait dit "Les français n'ont
pas de mots pour entrepreneur, sachant
que c'est un mot français d'origine et
donc que l'État doit doivent être
entrepreneur est une chose qu'elle nous
rappelle très utilement."
Taric.
Bon, moi j'allais aussi dire Black Box
Society, mais
il y en a il y en a je vais en proposer
d'autres là en ce moment. Moi, je suis
fasciné par les Ukrainies. J'ai toujours
aimé cette idée euh donc il y avait
Faland mais j'ai découvert alors
malheureusement euh
il faut que tuexpliques parce que
euh alternative timeline timeline
alternative euh what if
qu'est-ce qui se serait passé si les
États-Unis avaient été euh colonisés par
les nazi j'avais j'étais fasciné par ce
film qui a été inspiré du livre
Faverland où on imagine Hitler gagner la
guerre et donc rencontré
Non ça c'est c'est un autre une autre
chronist le maître de ha château mais
c'était rencontré Kennedy à Berlin et le
film est absolument génial. Le livre est
génial nazis sur la lune, c'est lequel ?
Non.
Ah, bonne question. J'ai souvenir. J'ai
souvir. Ou
mais j'ai découvert un livre qui
s'appelle Satiska Night.
Vasiska
Knight dont le la qui a été longtemps
écrit sous un pseudonyme et la femme qui
l'a écrit me me revient pas. Mais il a
été écrit en 1937
H
où il comment euh les l'Allemagne nazie
dominait le monde 500 ans dans le futur.
Donc on avait déjà imaginé la deuxème
guerre mondiale et c'est un bouquin
fascinant.
Euh moi j'aime bien aussi le le
capitalisme de surveillance mais euh je
vais choisir un autre livre d'une
personne que j'aime beaucoup qui
s'appelle Shery Turkle qui
Sherry Turkle
euh qui est un peu ma une de mes maîtres
à penser sur la question de la de la de
la vision de la du numérique et de la
sociologie qui s'appelle Alone Together.
où elle a elle a un peu décrit euh ce
cette vision du numérique. Et puis après
pour tous ceux qui aiment le hack et qui
ont envie de lire le bouquin de
référence, alors je le dis maintenant
parce que j'avais l'impression que tout
le monde l'avait lu, terminal compromise
de Vinchau euh qui est un qui explique
en fait le concept de perlar
électronique
et qui a été un des pionniers. Alors il
y a aussi le nid de coucou de Clifford
Stall qui faut relire. Euh Clevelard
Scold qui a qui a euh suite à une erreur
de comptabilité d'un dollar a fait tout
ce travail de de découvert des de
découvrir des hackur euh allemands euh
qui avait du qui était plus ou moins
affilié au Chaos Computer Club qui
vendait les secrets au aux russes et
c'est écrit comme un un roman
incroyable. Et pour les gens qui veulent
voir un peu ce qui était l'internet dans
les années 80, donc avant même que
l'internet soit officiellement, c'est
encore la panette, c'est fantastique,
c'est écrit, il y a pas besoin d'être
très bon techniquement, mais ce type est
est est brillantissime, un peu dingo. Et
il a euh il nous avait prévenu tout ce
qu'on tout ce dont on parle, il a écrit
un deuxième livre beaucoup plus sombre
sur l'avenir du numérique et qui
correspond exactement un peu au thème
qu'on a abordé aujourd'hui.
Vous connaissez le travail d'Alan
Damasio. Oui, bien sûr.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
quelque chose d'impérissable qui va
rester sur le net.
Ah ! Alors, moi, j'aime pas l'idée
d'apprendre à coder parce que c'est
toujours le truc le poncif,
mais apprendre à être curieux, c'est euh
apprendre à maîtriser les sources
d'information. Je dirais que la veille
devient une déformation un peu comme le
le le la maintenance informatique est
une est un métier qu'on doit tous
apprendre douloureusement
vu le nombre de
tous tous tous tous tous tous tous tous
et on y passe un temps. On n pas dans
notre vie on dit qu'on passe un tiers du
temps à à s'occuper d'un ordinateur sans
être productif sur un ordinateur ce qui
est déjà énorme. Donc moi, je dirais que
apprendre à maîtriser les sources
d'information, les mettre en
perspective, je parle pas de de fact
checking, c'est pas le terme, mais je
dirais comprendre comment on nourrit sa
réflexion par rapport à un sujet,
étendre et croiser les sources
d'information, c'est peut-être le le
nouveau
la nouvelle nécessité humaine des temps
qui viennent.
Alors, j'ai l'inverse, c'est apprendre à
s'exprimer clairement. Oui,
j'ai eu une chance une fois euh euh de
me retrouver pendant une demi-heure seul
avec Steve Jobs
il y a des années quand il était en il
était au au au down de sa carrière quand
il faisait Next.
Ouais.
Et ce qui m'avait fasciné déjà, on m'a
dit "Oui, c'est un chatur, il connait
rien la technologie." qui boss il avait
tous les trucs qu'il avait vu étaient
bon c'est le wifi USB enfin c'est tout
ça c'est des décisions donc il
maîtrisait parfaitement la technologie
mais il avait une capacité
d'éloquence de réduire ses idées simples
qui étaient fascinantes et et encore
aujourd'hui il y a plein de gens qui
veulent se prendre pour Steve Jobs mais
ils imitent le style la simplicité les
les les PowerPoint mais sa vraie force
c'est qu'il était capable de réduire
l'essence de ce qu'il était de ce qu'il
voulait
et je pense que chacun a le droit de
penser ce qu'il veut mais il doit
apprendre à l'exprimer.
Ça c'est un travail
à synthétiser et à résumer la
quintessence de ces idées.
Absolument.
Voulez les défendre
et surtout
et les défendre. Monsieur
vous voulez rajouter quelque chose
? C'est bon
messieurs. Merci.
Merci.
Merci beaucoup.
[Musique]